[musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Vous avez le droit de dire bonsoir hein.
C'est ça.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Sinkerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Nicolas Conquer.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Merci de votre invitation. Je suis
Nicolas Conquer. Je suis
franco-américain. Je vis en France et je
viens de produire un essai qui s'appelle
Vert français. Je suis également le
fondateur d'un institut transatlantique
qui s'appelle Western Arc qui vise à
réconcilier les deux rives de
l'Atlantique entre l'efficacité
américaine et la profondeur européenne.
Je suis un observateur de courant
politique entre les États-Unis et la
France et je vise à rétablir à travers
un pont transatlantique différentes
formations politiques et différents
mouvements et des idées.
Fort chour. Absolument.
Toutouf Bluetooth
Bluetooth. Bluetooth. Olivier Laurellie
toujours geek un petit peu moins dans la
sécurité informatique parce que j'ai
envie de prendre mes distances avec ça.
Donc j'ai beaucoup plus de temps
maintenant pour faire autre chose et du
coup je fais autre chose et je vais pas
vous dire quoi.
Donc ce soir on va parler liberté
d'expression DSA Europe, États-Unis un
peu géopolitique peut-être peut-être un
peu aussi économie. On va essayer de
puiser dans vos cerveaux votre prisme de
lecture, essayer de vous comprendre, se
comprendre.
On va vous demander de vous expliquer
auprès de notre communauté pour nous
livrer vos arcanes, l'arborescence de
votre raisonnement.
Nicolas,
comment ça se passe en terme de liberté
d'expression ? Quelle est votre
perception en Europe ? Est-ce qu'il y a
un rétrécissement de la liberté
d'expression ? Est-ce que l'Europe est
en train de se battre contre de
l'ingérence américaine via les
plateformes américaines ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
On entend une petite musique de fond qui
qui se tram ces derniers temps. Emmanuel
Macron a balancé pure le free first
speech pure bullshit. Il fallait aussi
mettre au pas les réseaux sociaux. Donc
on voit qu'il y a une vraie attaque qui
traduit en fait et qui traduit et qui
trahit une idéologie. Euh c'est pas
seulement juste de la sémantique ou de
la rhtorique. Je pense que on est en
train de voir qu'il y a deux conceptions
de la liberté d'expression entre la
vision américaine qui est plus libérale,
plus pragmatique et une vision
européenne qui est continentale,
républicaine et très idéaliste, très
restrictive de la liberté d'expression
pour défendre un bien commun ou des
valeurs quelconque mais avec une
instrumentalisation de cette protection
de la démocratie qui vise à étouffer
toute forme de débat contestataire. Et
donc on a vu différentes occurrences qui
à mon avis menacent profondément le
débat démocratique et la sérénité qu'on
est censé avoir à plus forte raison dans
une année charnière en vue des élections
françaises présidentielles.
Quel type d'occurrence ? Bien ça a été
dénoncé notamment à travers le discours
de Munich par Jed Vans l'an dernier à la
conférence de sécurité.
Pour ceux qui l'ont pas vu, ça ressemble
à quoi ?
Donc c'était le vice-président
américain, premier déplacement à
l'international. Il intervient lors de
cette conférence de sécurité, ça fait
tout juste 1 an où il vous dit purement
et de manière très frontale avec une
grande franchise et une honnêteté qui
peut caractériser les États-Unis et qui
peut surprendre les Européens. Je veux
dire que la plus grande menace auxquelle
vous êtes confronté, elle vient pas de
l'extérieur. C'est ni la Russie ni la
Chine. La plus grande menace pour vos
démocraties occidentales, elle vient de
l'intérieur. C'est le mépris que vous
pouvez avoir vis-à-vis de certaines
idées et la volonté de cadnasser la
liberté d'expression.
Les les faits
présentés concernaient notamment
l'inversion du scrutin en Roumanie, des
gens qui se font interpeller au petit
matin pour des posts qu'ils ont fait sur
des réseaux sociaux. Donc moins de de
manifestations concrètes en France, mais
il y a des occurrences un peu partout en
Europe et qui euh qui peuvent de fait
euh faire tâche d'huile et venir encore
une fois corseter cette liberté
d'expression qui est déjà mis bien à mal
en France euh notamment via des
officines politiques comme l'Arcom qui
cherchent à contrôler la liberté
d'expression sur le paysage audiovisuel
mais désormais
l'ARCOM c'est pas une officine
politique. Bah alors de fait une une
autorité administrative indépendante qui
est rattachée au ministère de la culture
mais qui échappe au pouvoir du
législateur. Je le dis d'autant plus,
vous pourrez dire que j'ai du skin in
the game, je suis concerné parce que je
suis
pas Smissy ou sinon je me fâche, on est
sur
j'ai de l'argent en jeu dans le sens où
ça fait un an que je suis face au
Conseil d'État enfin face à l'ARCOM
devant le Conseil d'État pour dénoncer
une décision abusive qu'ils ont pris à
mon encontre me caractérisant de
personnalité politique du champ
politique français eu égard à un
parcours de 3 semaines que j'ai eu en
politique en brigant un mandat alors que
je n'ai jamais été élu. J'ai été
candidat lors de la dernière désolution
donc au législative sous une étiquette
LRRN donc sous la famille politique de
l'UDR. Il y a une proximité mais de fait
je ne suis pas élu, je ne brigue pas de
nouveaux mandats et on voudrait
caractériser mes prises de position dans
l'espace médiatique qui concerne
davantage des sujets en lien avec les
États-Unis, la géopolitique comme étant
des prises de parole d'une formation
politique et donc un décompte de temps
de parole. ce qui est clairement abusif
et ça montre encore une fois de plus que
votre législateur si il laisse le champ
libre au régulateur et bien on a ces ces
personnes qui peuvent agir de manière
politique et outrepasser leur droits et
déterminer s'arroger le droit de décider
qui doit parler ou non mais surtout à
l'image de ce qu'on va voir dans le DSA
faire pression sur les plateformes pour
les réseaux sociaux ou faire pression
sur les éditeurs pour les chaînes pour
que eux-mêmes régulent qui doit ou non
parler. Donc c'est très cynique, c'est
très sournois et c'est très délétaire
pour la propagation et pour un échange
de débat sain et un pluralisme pour
lequel cette cette agence est censée
œuvrer. Je me fais l'avocat du diable,
mais l'ARCOM aussi doit veiller à ce que
les choses soient correctement rangées,
que les gens aient un temps de parole
équilibré et que il y ait pas des gens
qui invancent en sous-main ou en
sous-marin sur tel ou tel type de chose.
Et si vous me permettez de vous
reprendre sur la la franchise
américaine,
l'Irak,
les armes de destruction massive,
c'était pas très franc, céit un
peut-être un mensonge ou un gros
mensonge envoyé. Non
non mais c'est un grand mensonge qui a
causé des centaines de milliers de morts
et c'était vraiment une croisade
démocratique portée par George Debou
Bouche et ce courant néoconservateur euh
qui était d'ailleurs un candidat
républicain et je le redis, je me suis
pas présenté comme tel mais j'ai été le
porte-parole de ce mouvement républicain
américain. C'est comme ça que j'ai pu
faire quelques apparitions dans la
médias. J'ai désormais fait un pas de
côté et j'interviens pas pour faire du
damage control tant du trumpisme que du
parti républicain. Contrô
pardon. Euh je viens pas faire le
service aprèsvente ou me positionner
comme le le le défenseur de ce qui a pu
être mené. D'autant plus il y a 20 ans
et je le dis dans mon livre que je me je
me retrouvais pas dans ce parti
républicain qui voulait aller exporter
des idéaux à coup de bombe. Et le fait,
il y a dans la position de Trump qu'on
l'aime ou non une volonté et c'est
d'ailleurs marqué noir sur blanc dans
son document de sécurité nationale la
volonté de ne pas aller faire de
construction de régime pour être
français en français dans le texte et de
ne pas souscrire à des conflits qui n'en
finissent pas pour apporter des idéos
qui qui en fait ne correspondent pas aux
attentes du peuple.
Olivier Bluetooth. Alors je tiens à
précis. Oui, pardon, j'étais relancé.
Je tiens [rires] pard
que
tu es à l'initiative de cette interview.
Exactement.
Et que tu as utilisé ton jeton de
priorité, ton seul jeton de priorité
pour attirer mon attention sur un sujet
d'actualité brûlant qui est la liberté
d'expression. Je te demanderai de
rebondir, d'amender, de compléter avec
ton point de vue sur ce qui vient d'être
dit, ce qui a été fait en Europe et ce
qui peut menacer aussi la liberté
d'expression en Europe.
D'accord. Bon, il y a pas mal de points
déjà en fait sur lesquels je vais
revenir très très brièvement.
D'une part, la citation exacte de
Macron, c'est pas respeit pur bullshit,
c'est pas exactement ce qui a été dit.
Il faut je demande de vérifier
simplement la citation exacte.
Travaille chez French Response toi. Non,
pas du tout.
Euh secondement, le cette élection en
Roumanie, je suis assez d'accord. C'est
un truc sur lequel il faut conserver un
œil. Cependant,
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en
Roumanie ? En Roumanie,
c'était donc pour les c'était des
élections présidentielles, il me semble,
il y a eu une campagne de com des
démocrates, des socio-démocrates
européens qui se fait qui s'est fait
pirater tout simplement par un par un
gars qui a beaucoup de pognons et qui a
réussi en fait à détourner le message
original de de ces de ces de ces
libérées.
et en piratance campagne a mis en avant
un candidat qui est sorti de nulle part
et qui était plutôt catalogué à
l'extrême droite, on va dire. Et
effectivement, il y a eu un vrai
parasitage qui justifie il a fait une
mitéran.
Je sais pas s'il a fait une mitéran là.
Il y a eu un un piratage.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire une mitéran ?
Je sais pas ce que tu
faire monter le Front National pour
détruire la droite.
Ah ça s'est pas passé exactement comme
ça. Il y a vraiment eu un piratage d'une
campagne de comistribué
à plein de tiktokeurs et évidemment
fing,
c'est complètement de la structurfing.
On est on est on est complètement
là-dedans. Et évidemment ben ce qui
s'est passé c'était plus qu'un
parasitage et je c'est mon point de vue
hein. Tel parasitage avec un piratage ça
a été prouvé. Je pense qu'on pouvait
annuler l'élection.
Sachant que c'est historique, c'est
inédit, ça n'avait jamais été fait et
que en soit pardon, je donne le bâton de
présence. Pardon, pardon, je te laisse
reprendre. Pardon
à Je vais enchaîner sur le DSA
directement. Là, on va avoir un point
d'accord. Je pense que le DSA est une
énorme connerie, mais alors pour
d'autres raisons. Euh
c'est quoi le DSA ? le DSA. Donc c'est
en gros euh c'est voilà le Digital
Service Act, c'est en gros en fait une
une conception de la modération que aux
États-Unis on pourra appeler censure
effectivement euh je pense qu'on peut
également appeler ça censure, je suis
assez d'accord avec ça. Euh mais c'est
pas une censure étatique. soit délégué à
des associations, à des signaleurs de
confiance, le fait de pouvoir trouver
des contenus, enfin signaler des
contenus aux plateformes qui seront
obligés de les retirer parce que sinon
ell risque 6 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires mondial.
Euh partant là, tu te doutes bien que il
y a forcément de la surcensure et que ce
système de base ne peut pas être bon
pour une raison.
Est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est retiré
? Est-ce que c'est dééférencé ? Est-ce
que c'est shadow bané ?
Ouais, tu fais très très bien de poser
la question. En fait, tu as plusieurs
types de de sanctions. Soit euh tu vas
te faire carrément sauter ton compte.
C'est arrivé à beaucoup de gens
notamment pendant le Covid. Et le truc
qui est beaucoup plus pernicieux et qui
en plus et hors la loi si tu lis le DSA,
c'est le shadow ban. Parce que dans le
DSA, normalement, tu es censé être
informé de ce qui t'arrive. Je connais
personne qui est shadow ban et qui est
informé de ce qui lui arrive. Donc déjà
en fait si tu veux on part du principe
que tu as une censure qui n'est qui
n'est pas étatique. Ils vont dire "Nous,
on fait pas de censure en amont, c'est
pas l'État qui censure." Ben non, ils
ont délégué à des signaleurs de
confiance, ils ont une autorité et il
ils remontent le truc. Alors le truc est
pas nouveau. En fait, ça avait commencé
avec ADOPI. Si tu te rappelles bien, à
l'époque d'Adopi,
c'était les aillants de droit qui
avaient mandaté une société qui
s'appelait TMG et qui était en charge de
repérer les gens qui faisaient du
téléchargement sur le Pierre Tôt Pire.
Affilleur toi que j'ai reçu ma première
lettre de signalement il y a il y a
quelques mois là, il y a pas longtemps
parce que je fais tourner un VPN. En
2008,
pas du tout. Je fais tourner un VPN et
il y a un français qui est venu
télécharger La Reine des Neiges ou je
sais pas quoi en fait sur sur
même pas un dessin animé mec, vraiment
un dessin animé quoi. Et euh ben j'ai
reçu ma première lettre. Bon bref,
passons. Mais le truc qui est
intéressant c'est que ça a été un petit
peu le le on le savait à l'époque, on
avait gueulé là-dessus. On savait qu'on
était en train de de privatiser la
justice. Tu vois, tu donnes en fait à
une société privée mandaté en plus par
des ayants en droit. Donc on se passe
complètement du juge. Et ben qu'est-ce
qu'on sur quoi on arrive aujourd'hui en
fait ? On arrive sur les propos sur
plein de trucs comme ça. Et alors je
peux dire que la définition des propos
euh en 20 ans, faut voir comment là
c'est un truc de dingue. On est passé du
néonazie à euh normal ?
Non je trouve pas que ça soit normal.
C'est normal.
Non non. Alors le néozi oui c'est normal
effectivement parce qu'on a une loi qui
dit que tu peux pas être visioniste
machin sans encore on pourrait en
discuter parce que ça se discute pas
non alors ça se discute pas en revanche
je pense foncièrement que si tu as une
approche qui est la mienne en fait qui
est une approche pinosienne la liberté
d'expression
ou on est en France mon pote. Spinoza,
tu te le mets. OK.
Spinoza est quand même à l'origine, tu
vois, des lumières. Donc je pense qu'il
a enfin voilà. Donc pour replacer un
petit peu le truc, on est en 1670, le
mec est juif, excommunier, il se fait
censurer son bouquin, donc la total euh
parce qu'il attaque, c'est pas qu'il
attaque mais il fait une dissociation
entre clerg et et la République, pas la
République à l'époque, ni la démocratie,
mais la politique. Et il oppose la
raison et la superstition.
Partant de là, il se dit "Ben voilà, la
liberté d'expression, il une réflexion
qui est ultra intéressante là-dessus. Il
se dit que si l'État commence à censurer
n'importe quel propos, à empêcher les
idées en fait de de de de se propager,
bah c'est une pure folie parce que le
peuple se retournera forcément contre
lui."
Et c'est ce qu'on fait en Europe en ce
moment.
Tu tu trouves que le peuple se retourne
là ?
Ça commence.
Il y a ton voisin qui t'a demandé la
parole
évidemment. Ouais. Ouais, je sais pas si
tu as terminé mais je rebondir mais le
fait effectivement sur évidemment on
sera d'accord pour dire qu'il faut
condamner le nazisme mais plutôt que
d'avoir un arsenal législatif je pense
qu'il vaut mieux le combattre par
opposer des arguments contre les
arguments. Moi je suis partant du
principe que le meilleur antiseptique
c'est la lumière et que il faut montrer
l'insuffisance de ces raisonnements et
qu'on arrive rapidement avec des lois
liberticides sous couvert de nobles
intentions qui vont derrière venir
s'appliquer à d'autres thématiques. Tu
as vu cette dérive totalitaire de venir
cadnasser, censurer le discours peut
venir rapidement se retourner contre
nous. Et je pense que effectivement tu
as dit que il y a eu une extension de ce
champ de la censure.
Tu tu as parlé donc de Spinozza. Moi je
pense on peut faire également Stuart M
aussi au milieu du 19e siècle qui dit
qu'en fait toute forme de censure est
illégitime car une idée peut contenir
une part de vérité et que encore une
fois ça ça rejoint cette conception à la
fois continentale républicaine
européenne d'une vision très très
linéaire de la liberté d'expression et
celle plutôt inspirée des États-Unis qui
est un un marché des idées marketplace
of ideas qui
en en 1919 je prends un volontairement
quelque chose chose qui peut s faire éco
à des situations qu'on vit aujourd'hui
en France et en Europe, mais il y a un
arrêt de la Cour suprême qui fait date
sur pas tant pour la décision mais pour
la la dissension, c'estàdire la voie
contradictoire qui avait été émise. Vous
avez des ouvriers qui font des qui
diffusent des tractes qui dénoncent
l'implication des États-Unis dans la
guerre contre la Russie et on se pose la
question de savoir si c'est une forme
d'ingérence. Est-ce que ça devrait être
considéré comme du hate speech ? Est-ce
que c'est contraire à l'espionnage acte
? Et à l'époque la décision de la Cour
suprême dit bah en fait non, on a ça
entrave la liberté enfin c'est c'est une
menace à la liberté d'expression à la
société l'ordre. Donc on va le bannir.
Mais euh c'est la décision de Holmes,
donc d'un juge à la Cour suprême,
consiste à dire que il faut au contraire
permettre à ce que il y ait ce ce marché
libre des idées qui rentrent en
compétition. Et c'est ce qui par la
suite a été contesté et on pourrait être
d'accord ou non, mais la Cour suprême
euh à travers un arrêt qui a été très
connu, Missouri versus Board euh
consiste à dire queévidemment vous
pouvez ne pas être d'accord avec les
idées du Cuclux Clan, mais combien même
elle serait détestable, elle doit être
combattue dans l'espace public par des
idées et des arguments et des
contrearguments plutôt que de
l'interdire et que effectivement aux
États-Unis, on peut voir qu'il y a des
mouvements néonazies, tout ce que vous
voulez ou terrible qui puissent exister
mais littéralement de manière très très
résiduelle. euh qui plutôt que de se
voir victimiser parce qu'elle serait
censurée, condamné politiquement euh et
qui est pour moi une bonne manière de de
combattre ces idéologies plutôt que
d'imposer des lois d'hberticides qui
ensuite on voit tombe dans une dans un
continuum et une dérive qui comme on le
dit derrière et je l'avais présenté ce
mécanisme de censure par procuration
fait qu'on n pas du tout de transparence
sur les décisions qui vont être motivées
pour retirer des contenus au point même
où je vais le dire c'est l'Europe qui
s'en en orgueil que par rapport à ce que
tu disais sur les les contenus qui sont
supprimés ou retirés, c'est 97 % de ces
contenus qui sont pas qui sont
directement du fait des plateformes.
Donc encore une fois, c'est pas l'État
qui se salie les mains en disant bah
tiens, on va blâmer ça. C'est
préactivement de manière préemptive les
plateformes qui vont censurer ce contenu
et qui agissent de manière très
proactive pour éviter cette fameuse
sanction budgétaire de 6 %.
97 % retiré c'est ça ces chiffres, ils
viennent d'où ? Bon, ça c'est euh dans
euh pas les pas enfin la commission qui
s'en orgueille de tout ça qui affiche
c'est des contenus qui étaient légaux
d'ailleurs derrière il y a différentes
appréciations mais en fait on n' pas de
transparence. C'est ça l'enjeu, c'est
que il y a dans ce règlement du DSA qui
fait 107 pages et qui ensuite a été
réagrandie dans une opacité totale avec
une non séparation des pouvoirs parce
que ceux qui produisent la loi, donc la
Commission européenne et la même qui va
juger et imposer l'amende de 120
millions de dollars contre contre contre
Musk, c'est c'est le même pouvoir. Donc
ça pose aussi déjà un problème
philosophique de de de distinction de de
séparation des pouvoirs, mais de fait on
n pas de visibilité. Ils invoquent un
risque systémique qui pousse à ce que
dans l'eau, il y a peut-être des choses
qui tombent sous le coup de la loi, mais
qu'on puisse avoir une visibilité, une
transparence et de savoir si la
modération est justifiée ou si ça a un
excès pour savoir enfin de de manière
préventive pour éviter des amendes
record qui comme Musk et la plateforme X
a été victime fin décembre. Mais par
exemple, si euh nous on nous shadow ban,
qu'on enlève nos contenus euh et que
après on porte plainte et que un juge
dit euh c'était des propos euh des
invités tout à fait euh propres sur eux,
des propos qui méritaient d'être
écoutés, il risque d'y avoir des classes
action de youtubeurs, de tiktokeurs ou
quoi que ce soit contre les plateformes,
ça va leur coûter des millions d'euros.
Je prends l'exemple des Twitter files.
Vous avez suivi les les
Oui, de près. Oui, tout à fait. Ouais.
Donc pendant des républicains se sont vu
Shadow Banner, fermer leur compte
Twitter parce que il y avait un prisme
de lecture qui était dans le sens de Joe
Biden et
c'était compliqué par rapport à la
liberté d'expression et par rapport
c'est quel amendement la liberté
d'expression aux États-Unis ? le premier
amendement,
le le seul et l'unique d'ailleurs,
bah c'est le fondement de la démocratie
et d'ailleurs c'était tellement évident
que ça a pas été intégré lors de nos
premières constitution ou au moment de
la révolution parce que évidemment c'est
ce pourquoi on qu'on se battait aussi en
France d'avoir cette capacité libre
plutôt que d'être en Bastillé parce
qu'on aurait dit quelque chose qui
déplaisait au monarque.
Olivier, tu veux rebondir, tu demander ?
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. En fait, c'est
vraiment intéressant cette histoire
parce que quand tu regardes comment
éguer le premier amendement et ce qu'on
oppose au premier amendement avec notre
conception de la liberté d'expression au
niveau européen, alors c'est ça qui est
rigolo aussi. On a notre conception
française de la liberté d'expression,
mais euh on va être on tombe sous un DSA
qui est un texte européen. Donc ça veut
dire que chaque pays de de l'Union
européenne va devoir appliquer ce DSA,
le transposé
avec en gros la bonne morale, la bonne
machin locale. Donc ce qui sera censuré
dans un pays ne le sera pas forcément
dans un autre. Ça c'est un vrai problème
déjà. Maintenant, il y a un truc qui est
assez rigolo avec internet, c'est que
quand tu prends le premier amendement,
le truc il est plug and play, il
fonctionne. Il y a pas de problème. Tu
as pas besoin de le scalay parce que tu
as pas un milliard d'appels au meurtre
par jour. Et la limite du premier
amendement, tu m'arrêtes si je fais
erreur, c'est l'appel à la violence.
Donc en gros, tu fais un appel au
meurtre, là tu tombes sous le coup de la
loi, là on peut te censurer
et puis on peut te mettre en tôle.
Et on peut accessoirement te mettre en
tôle. Tout à fait.
Euh en France, c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué. En Europe, du coup, avec le
DSA, les proposineux, ce que je te
disais tout à l'heure, ben c'est
peut-être des millions, des dizaines de
millions par jour. J'en ai aucune idée
en fait.
La justice peut pas suivre. Donc, on se
retrouve obligé d'automatiser. On se
retrouve obligé de se passer du juge. Ça
c'est un problème.
C'est un problème tout simplement parce
que la Constitution française déjà te
dit que tu as loin un procès équitable.
On s'assoit dessus.
Ces lois, elles diffèrent, on l'a dit,
en Europe, c'est pas les mêmes. Et donc,
les standards ne sont pas les mêmes pour
des raisons historiques. Typiquement en
Allemagne, ils ont des délits qui visent
à ce qu'on ne peut pas faire d'injure,
voir même de critique vis-à-vis des
personnalités politiques. Et là,
typiquement, vous avez un retraité de 86
ans qui s'est vu fracasser sa porte au
réveil à 6h du matin parce qu'il a fait
un poste dans lequel il a mis un emoji
Pinocchio pour Fredrich Schmert.
Est-ce qu'on se rend compte ? Je pense
qu'on
et et donc du coup il y a il y a il y a
c cette conséquence avec effectivement
c'est c'est instruit et ça peut donner
lui à déd je suis pas en train de dire
que ça va être répliqué mais à travers
cet élément anecdotique on peut voir que
les standards vont être abaissés de
manière de plus en plus restrictive et
qu' aussi ce règlement du DSA d'une
certaine manière quandbien même il
serait européen, il y a une vocation
d'extraterritorialité.
il va s'appliquer au-delà des frontières
européennes et je pense que sur votre
plateforme ici sur Syerview, vous avez à
cœur cette souveraineté. La souveraineté
numérique, elle est au cœur de nos
priorités et bah des enjeux de demain
avec notre sing Western Arc, on a
produit une note en ce sens mais qui
montre que on critique volontiers
l'extratériatalité du droit américain.
Vous avez reçu d'ailleurs quelqu'un
d'Abstolm qui a été vement victime de ça
et s'en est malheureux et j'ai une
grande compassion et une sympathie pour
lui et son combat Fred Pi de Charlstom.
Mais en l'occurrence, cette extrateté du
droit et cette souveraineté numérique,
elle vise aussi à venir impacter cette
liberté d'expression en dehors des
frontières et potentiellement bah des
gens qui ont des conceptions plus
libérales, plus permissives de la
liberté d'expression.
Ouai. Alors le l'instrumentalisation de
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
ou sa militarisation pour ennuyer
quelques sociétés françaises et
européennes et les mettre au pas. On
pourra revenir après un peu plus tard.
Olivier.
Oui. Alors bon le vieux monsieur
allemand vous inquiétez pas, ça s'est
très très bien passé. La procédure a
arrêté a été arrêtée après quelques
heures. Il a pas fait de prison. Il a je
crois qu'il a même pas fait de garde à
vue. Euh premier point,
il on ils lui ont fracassé sa porte.
Je j'en doute honnêtement, j'en doute.
Donc mais c'est toujours le même truc en
fait. Tu balances une news comme ça sur
les réseaux sociaux, c'est ce que je
reproche d'ailleurs en fait au compte
Trump France, tu le sais. Euh c'est de
prendre des la vérité parcellaire. Il y
a effectivement une procédure qui a été
lancée. Là, c'est un exemple mais je
peux t'en citer 150 comme ça. Je je les
vois passer en fait tous les jours. Euh
donc forcément ben quand tu balances en
fait un tweet comme ça, tu fais réagir
les gens. En fait les c'est c'est un
petit peu la mécanique de Trump en fait.
Quand tu regardes bien, tu as la
répétition, tu as l'appel à l'émotion,
la stigmatisation
et ben tout ça en fait ça fait réagir
les gens. effectivement, c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne très très bien sur
les réseaux sociaux,
mais c'est pas suffisant. Si tu es si tu
t'attaches au fond, en fait, si tu vas
jusqu'au bout en fait de ton
information, bah tu te rends compte que
bah l'information, elle est là pour
cliver.
Et c'est pas en clivant que tu arrives à
discuter avec des gens, à opposer les
idées. C'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne. Alors, c'est bien au début
pour se brancher comme je l'ai fait de
manière très discourtoise,
pardon,
désolé
mais euh à partir du moment où on a une
exigence républicaine,
il faut qu'on on ait des débats
raisonnés. Et ça implique une certaine
forme d'instruction, ça implique de
l'apaisement et ça implique de pas
cliver, de stigmatiser.
Mais tu vis un peu sur la planète
Bisounours mon grand.
Pas du tout.
Je je me fais l'avocat du diable. Les
politiques se font élire en en excitant
leur z. C'est un vrai problème.
Ils instrumentalisent, ils militarisent
la communication politique en instylant
du venin pour de plus en plus
radicaliser leurs oua à exciter les
zones les plus primitives du cerveau
pour faire des gens engagés jusqu'à la
moelle pour son parti. ça devient
compliqué quand ça s'affronte
directement dans les rues. On a une
crise économique en Europe qui commence
à peser très très lourd sur la classe
moyenne. On a un pouvoir politique qui
est démuni par rapport aux ingérences
extérieures, ingérences étrangères de
n'importe quel type de pays. La Russie,
les États-Unis, le Qatar, le Maroc,
Israël, tout le monde. On a laissé
l'Europe et surtout la France aux quatre
vents parce que le l'éducation nationale
n'a pas eu les les crédits ou l'envie ou
les capacités d'endurcir les cerveaux de
notre jeune génération qui est exposé
maintenant à des algorithmes entièrement
designés pour être addictif, renforcer
les biaiss, ne
sous des prétextes de on donne des
choses que les gens aiment.
Donc c'est prendre le temps, c'est
terminé. Il y a que sur Syerview, on
prend le temps.
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. Tout à fait. En
fait, le temps du débat est ultra
important mais quand tu regardes à nos
parlementaires, malheureusement passent
leur temps sur des débats. Regarde ce
qui s'est passé avec le vote du budget.
Les mecs, ils ont chaté, ils ont chaté
et puis on se retrouve avec un texte qui
a rien à voir avec de quoi avec ce de
quoi ils ont causé. Tu te demandes à
quoi ça sert en fait tout ça et et
forcément ça fout en colère les gens.
Moi je suis en colère quand je vois ça.
Quand on passe mes je sais pas combien
de semaines sur un truc débile comme
l'attaque du
C'est quoi l'antidote ?
L'antidote bah ça c'est une bonne
question en fait. Moi je diviserai déjà
l'Assemblée nationale par deux. Je pense
pas qu'on ait besoin de 577 mecs qui se
tapent dessus. Je pense que tu en mets
la moitié, ça suffit amplement.
On commence par ça déjà parleront
peut-être mieux. Euh deuxièmement euh
les ces histoires de groupes politiques
machin, enfin voilà, d'alliance, de
bidules et tout. Euh c'est pas quelque
chose qui est correct en fait pour les
gens qui votent pour eux.
Nicolas, on voit Trump être relativement
véhémément concernant
monsieur Breton, ce grand chef
d'entreprise très efficace,
ce ce grandateur
de la souveraineté européenne.
Pourquoi ?
Euh pourquoi ? parce que on a quelqu'un
qui a un ancien commissaire Thierry
Breton qui s'est fait démissionner suite
à des prises d'initiative malencontreuse
qui était rappelons-le hein pendant la
campagne de 2024 Elon Musk propose à
Donald Trump de venir faire un entretien
sans sa plateforme et avant même que
l'entretien ait eu lieu, Thierry Breton
de son propre fait prend sa plume,
envoie une missive en disant "Mais
attendez, je vous alerte que si vous
avez du contenu qui serait contraire à
nos règles et bien on censurerait
l'entretien. ou voir même on bannirait
votre plateforme. Je veux dire, on est
dans une espèce de de crime par
préméditation ou par suspicion de
culpabilité qui était absolument indu et
une forme de s'ingérer dans sa scrutin.
Ça lui a valu de se faire démissionner
mais son acharnement contre la
propagation d'idées et la liberté
d'expression sur les plateformes en a
fait l'objet d'une sanction sur le fait
qu'il ne pu puisse accéder sur le
territoire américain. Son visa a été
interdit. Il n'est pas le seul. derrière
lui, lui, il essaie de se mettre un peu
un peu le bouqu émissaire ou encore une
espèce de de victime sacrificielle euh
derrière moi, c'est toute l'Europe qui
est visé. Ben non, mon garçon. Euh la
personne la Commission européenne
personne ne sait vu son son visa
suspendu. Il y a quatre autres personnes
qui qui sont visées dans ce sens.
Euh un des d'autres activistes,
monsieur Botorel, non ?
Euh alors, ça pas été confirmé. Et
d'ailleurs, quand Macron dernièrement
allait demander à Donald Trump de
revenir sur la décision vise en breton,
il a pas parlé de Brell notamment. Donc
Botrell, c'est celui un député affilié
Renaissance qui a lancé ce signalement
et qui a déclenché cette enquête qui a
débouché sur un raid ou une perquisition
qui avait manifestement des motivations
politiques sur les locaux de Twitter
XFance à Paris à la suite duquel nous
avons organisé une mobilisation pour
dénoncer cette mobilisation et cet acte
judiciaire abusif. Euh et donc les gens
douchent avec vous euh
bah de fait la défense de la liberté
d'expression, c'est quelque chose de
plus transpartisan qui existe. Moi je ne
suis euh je suis très inclusif comme on
dit. Vous voyez euh pour moi c'est pas
quelque chose du centre de droite ou de
gauche et je tends la main à qui qui
veut venir. Euh moi j'étais surtout
surpris des gens de gauche.
C'était pas tant qui était là, c'est
surtout qui était absent. il y en avait
mais moi je demande pas le leurs
affiliations politiques. Pour moi,
encore une fois, je suis pas d'accord
mais je défends un principe. Je défends
pas des personnes ou des colleur
politique. Il s'avère que j'ai des gens
qui ont accepté de venir et qui ont
témoigné. J'ai même par euh par
cohérence donné le micro un peu en mode
scène ouverte. Euh il y a une prise de
risque mais il y a une volonté de
défendre un principe et pas des
personnes ou des couleurs politiques.
Euh si derrière euh je constate juste
qu'il y en a des gens qui se mouillent
sur ce sujet et qui ont envie de
dénoncer euh cet acte qui avait un vrai
scandale et vraie motivation politique
euh et que certains sont restés
silencieux et qui pour moi c'est
particulièrement inquiétant parce qu'on
voit que bah nos dirigeants et le
système judiciaire il passent à l'acte
et nous on laisse faire. Donc jusqu'où
est-ce qu'on va se laisser muser dans ce
sens ? et je pense que par la suite la
situation a quand même pris une ampleur
qui vise quand même à la désescalade
même si ce feuilleton n'est pas terminé
mais encore une fois le fait de viser la
filiale X France n'était purement mais
injustifié les algorithmes de Grock les
contenus enfin c'est au vill de la
société M en Californie ou au Texas donc
c'est absolument d'une part un de poids
de mesure flagrant vis-à-vis des autres
plateformes et encore une fois quelque
chose de de purement scandaleux et
motivé politiquement notamment par ce
dép député dont il l'a mis en avance
était révélé par le Canard enchaîné mais
manifestement j'ai pas eu la
confirmation par le Homeland qu'est-ce
qu' a dit le Canard enchaîné
sur le fait que désormais il avait son
visa qui était réévoqué sachant que ça
ne sera pas le premier ni le dernier je
dis pas que c'est une bonne chose he
mais
ce député il a peut-être fait son boulot
était peut-être inquiet en voyant des
algorithmes qui renforçaient les idées
conservatrices
alors c'est pas du tout ce qui est mis
en avant et d'ailleurs ça serait très
grave alors là lui il mettent en avant
des biais sur les les pastilles bleues
qui sont le fait que vous pu payz un
abonnement premium sur les les
publicités sur du contenu
pédopornographique. Moi, j'en ai jamais
vu et je le condamne évidemment mais
quelle que soit la plateforme, quelle
que soit la personne qui est mettre en
avant et également sur la mise à
disposition des algorithmes en open
source auprès de certains chercheurs qui
ont qui ont évidemment voilà
c'est si c'est en open source, c'est
auprès de tout le monde, non ?
Bien sûr, mais c'était pas la dernière
version. Apparemment, il y avait une
discussion sur le fait que c'était une
version de 2023,
un petit peu plus que ça.
Donc non, mais ça c'est effectivement
c'est les motivations qui se sont mises
en avant. Si derrière ça serait pour
essayer de contrôler un éventuel biais
conservateur, c'est pas eux qui s'en
sont en chargés mais de fait vous avez
dans les médias des gens qui relaaient
selon une étude, on voit que le contenu
de Sarah Knafo est plus amplifié que
Rachidatis qui montre un biais populiste
par Musk. Alors que euh c'est c'est
vraiment des années
c'est très intéressant ce que vous
souvez, c'est-à-dire
on on a vu une
Euro députée euh brillantissime. Comment
elle s'appelle déjà ? Euh
Valérie
Ah Valérie
A
dire que l'Europe était assiégée
entre, je pense, si j'arrive à la
suivre, la Russie et les États-Unis,
des valeurs conservatrices
du côté de la Russie, des valeurs
conservatrices du côté des États-Unis
qui nous reprochent de perdre notre âme,
nos valeurs.
Il a peut-être mené l'investigation,
monsieur le député, pour vérifier que
c'était pas une turboingérence sous des
prétextes de liberté d'expression. Non,
je vais juste terminer avant de passer
le bâton de parole mais indépendamment
de sa sortie où évidemment ils sont en
service commandé parce qu'ils se sentent
très menacés ce bloc central,
votre interprétation
euh bah de fait moi je le vis sur des
plateaux avec un niveau d'escalade dans
la rhtorique, dans les menaces dont je
fais l'objet.
Quel type de menaces ? bah des menaces
d'allégation euh et des menaces
d'intimidation et de menaces de doxing.
Voilà, des choses très graves à un
contexte qui je dis plainte à chaque
fois
je vais porter plainte mais voilà c'est
une mobilisation, c'est un effort euh
c'est du temps et moi j'ai j'ai des
combats et j'ai de la production à mener
en parallèle euh mais de fait ces
intimidations, elles sont délétaires par
rapport à à un débat d'idée et je le dis
c'est une forme de néaccartisme qui vise
des gens qui seraient soupçonnés
d'intelligence ou de de collusion. Bref,
euh j'en termine pour dire que euh
au-delà de ces signalements signalement
vertueux de Valérie Ha et d'autres
personnalités qui cherche endosser une
tribune sur sur ces sur ces
questions-là, il y a des allégations qui
ont été diffusées par les par les
Républicains américains qui sont des
élus au Congrès qui ont fait part dans
des dossiers qui ont été produits par
des comités au Congrès sur des
ingérences européennes sur différents
scrutins en Europe dans H pays. en
Espagne, en France notamment lors des
élections européennes qui ont cherché à
infléchir, à moduler ou à s'ingérer dans
ces scrutin là. Donc moi, je suis pour
que ces preuves ou ces éléments, ces
allégations puissent être instruites et
qu'on puisse obtenir l'entière vérité
là-dessus. Mais ça nous fait écho à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur la
menace qui viendrait de l'intérieur dans
lequelle on fait pas encore suffisamment
confiance à la maturité de notre
démocratie à la liberté d'expression
pour que euh certaines personnes élues
ou non s'accordent ou s'arrogeent le
droit de décider sur ce qu'on aurait le
droit de de diffuser ou ce qu'il
faudrait museler en période électorale.
Donc c'est très préoccupant et j'attends
qu'on puisse faire la pleine lumière sur
c sur ces éléments qui ont été révélés.
Bon, moi j'ai des j'ai des mots qui me
qui me font de ligne. Bon, je vais
essayer de d'apporter un petit peu de de
mesures. Euh déjà, d'une part, il est
inex il est très mesuré.
Non, il y a des choses qui sont pas
mesurées. Le coût de la menace
intérieure, par exemple, tu vois, tout
ça, c'est une c'est un vocabulaire, une
rhtorique que je connais très très bien.
Euh, je vais revenir. Il est
Nicolette aura le droit de revenir après
derrière.
Il est il est pour moi déjà en fait
parfaitement inexact de de dire que le
député Borel ou quelques députés que ce
soit sont contre la liberté
d'expression. Ça n'a pas de sens. sympa
en plus votre
non seulement ça mais en plus c'est son
rôle il est député français il défend
une certaine conception de la liberté
d'expression qui est notre liberté
d'expression à la française. Je peux
être d'accord ou pas d'accord avec. Mais
l'objet c'est de la faire changer, de la
faire évoluer. À ce moment, moi je serai
d'avis à la faire évoluer un peu pour la
rendre un petit peu plus compatible avec
internet. Déjà, ce serait un premier
point. Mais en fait, le problème est
même pas là. Le vrai souci, c'est que
quand on se met à contester
le le le bien fondé d'un élu qui défend
la loi, ça n'a plus de sens. En fait, on
rentre, c'est même plus la contestation.
On est on n'est plus dans le débat là.
On est en train de stigmatiser un truc
et de dire bah on n'est pas d'accord, on
part on part faire la révolution et on
prend les fourches. C'est pas comme ça
que se passe ce débat républicain. Tu le
sais là, j'entends je revenais juste sur
le fait qu'il ait eu ou pas sa
suspension de visa indépendamment de ce
qui peut lui être reproché et s'il agit
conformément à la loi. Pour l'instant en
ce qui concernait l'aidement de
d'Emmanuel Macron visant à ce qu'on
puisse rétablir le droit à à Tirer
Breton de voyager, ça n'avait pas été le
cas pour Botorel. Juste petite
parenthèse, il y a d'autres personnes
dont on fait beaucoup moins de cas. euh
des élus du Rassemblement national
notamment euh que j'ai eu de source sûr
qui m'ont dit "Ben moi, malgré le mon
statut d'élu, mon visa et mon estat a
sauté et effectivement qu'on soit
d'accord ou non avec eux en Europe, on a
des cas qui sont d'autant plus flagrants
et symptomatiques."
Virginie Jordon, je crois Virginie
Jéron, tout à fait. Euh mais euh voilà,
le compte Strat qu'on l'aime ou qu'on
l'aime pas vis-à-vis de personnes qui
sont en Europe, il y a eu des sanctions
qui ont été effectuées à leur à leur
rencontre.
Strat
c'est
c'est un compte plutôt prousse et qui
avec avec d'autres
travaille depuis la Russie.
Honnêtement, je sais pas c'est pas mon
sujet mais de fait c'est c'est le
principe qu'on veut défendre. il peut
pas être à gémométrie variable. Euh et
ça renvoie aussi vers évidemment il y a
il y a d'autres personnes et qui étaient
lui pour le coup
aggloméré avec le cas de Thierry Breton
qui est un juge à la Cour pénale
internationale Nicolas Guillou qui lui
s'est fait complètement bannir de toutes
les plateformes euh dénumé enfin voilà
débranché de toutes les banques, de tous
les réseaux sociaux qui vit une
situation qui est autrement plus pénible
que d'avoir son visa suspendu quand vous
êtes Thierry Breton.
Ouais. Euh
je suis un petit peu embêté en fait avec
ces histoires de Je crois que le terme
c'était international réactionnaire le
terme qui avait été utilisé.
Je crois que c'est Macron qui a utilisé
ce terme
tout l'a repris. Oui, probablement.
En fait, si tu veux, le souci est pas
là. Quand tu prends les faits,
c'est-à-dire que tuas un organisme en
France qui s'appelle Viginum. Le viginum
en fait dépend euh dépend du SDGN, donc
je crois que c'est le cabinet du premier
ministre qui est derrière euh qui
monitore un petit peu tout ce qui est
tentative d'ingérence en France et euh
selon eux et je pense que je les crois
volontiers euh c'est eu à peu près une
douzaine de puissances qui sont des
menaces permanentes et actives sur
l'espace public français. Donc quand je
parle de l'espace public français, je
parle forcément d'internet, mais en plus
de ces états, tu as autre chose qui se
passe derrière parce que là, tu vois, on
en train de dire voilà, là il y a des
loups, il y a des loups, mais il y a
d'autres gens en fait derrière. Euh tu
as des particuliers aussi aujourd'hui.
Tu peux tout à fait être attaqué et
avoir une campagne de désinformation si
tu prends tiens cette histoire, tu sais,
du coup d'état en France.
Et ben l'histoire du une vidéo qui
tournait avec un coup d'état militaire
en France. Il y a un président africain
qui avait appelé Macron et Macron était
évidemment venu venu raconter ça à la
télé. Ben, on a appris à pas longtemps
que derrière en fait c'était pas un
état, c'était pas une tentative
d'ingérence russe parce que évidemment
on a tous [rires] pointé du même côté,
c'est forcément les Russes ce genre de
truc, sauf que c'était pas du tout les
Russes, c'était c'était quelqu'un comme
toi et moi.
C rég sans creuse.
C'était probablement ça venait peut-être
d'Afrique ou de je sais ou d'Inde ou je
sais pas où. Mais euh c'était une
opération commerciale. Faut comprendre
que ce genre de contenu ultra clivant
ultra viraux, ça fait du pognon. Donc on
se retrouve non seulement avec des
engértatiques, mais avec tout un bruit
de gens qui n'ont rien à voir avec des
officines étatiques et qui font ça pour
le pognon. Donc on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec une menace qui est
complètement diffuse, qui est qui est
qui qui est complètement hétérogène et
on sait pas lutter contre ça. Surtout
que tu tu vas en trouver allez je pense
que si tu en as 1 % qui passe et qui
fait beaucoup beaucoup de bruit déjà ça
fait beaucoup de mal mais il y en a
beaucoup qui tombent à l'eau. Tu vois,
beaucoup de trucs enfin des trucs qu'on
va savoir faux et tout mais le gros
souci c'est que il trouvent des caisses
de résonance en France avec des gens qui
sont plus ou moins cortiqué tu je vais
pas donner de nom mais vous les
connaissez tous en fait sur Twitter qui
sont tout le temps les premiers à
retweeter ce genre de truc tu vois bah
je vais en donner un vous connaissez
tous c'est Sylvano Trotard
que ce mec soit débile au point de
tweeter n'importe quoi comme il le fait
s'il le fait c'est que c'est rentable
tout simplement
dit qui dit qu'il fait de l'argent avec
son compte est monétisé. Enfin, tu peux
pas faire ça. Enfin, il fait forcément
du pognon avec. On connait pas.
C'est bah je pense vaut mieux qu'il se
fasse du pognon avec parce que sinon je
vais finir par croire qu'il est
complètement con.
Ouais, mais sans faire d'allégation, on
se monétise pas. C'est pas le Pérou
quoi. C'est pas deux trois retweet qui
font.
On connait pas cette personne. Donc
évidemment,
mais moi je connais son œuvre.
Il est pas là, il est pas là pour se
défendre. Euh je vais essayer de
recentrer un peu vos perceptions.
On voit que il y a quelques tensions
géopolitiques entre les États-Unis et la
France, quelques tensions entre l'Europe
et les États-Unis.
On voit que il y a des sanctions
applicables d'un côté comme de l'autre,
du moins surtout d'un côté. On on se
pose la question où ça va nous emmener ?
Est-ce que on va réussir à trouver un
terrain d'entente ? Est-ce qui va céder
en premier ? qui va trouver un
consensus, un chemin ? Est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a des pistes exploitables
où ça va continuer l'escalade,
l'escalade, l'escalade et est-ce que
l'Europe va finir par se faire
débrancher des gars femmes et de visa
sans avoir de solutions alternatives
déployable
à grande échelle ? Quand on voit que les
données françaises sont stockées aux
États-Unis,
ah maintenant, elles sont partout.
Et donc oui, non mais avec les failles
de sécurité, on fera une émission
spéciale avec d'autres potes.
Donc déconcentre pas, s'il te plaît.
Donc on voit que les données de nos
entreprises et y compris nos entreprises
stratégiques sont en partie stockée aux
États-Unis. Qu'est-ce qui va se passer
si les États-Unis disent après mou
réflexion de nos eurodéputés solaires
comme Valérie,
qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour le
business en Europe et en France ?
Nicolas
alors effectivement on pourrait faire
cette politique fiction et cette
escalade et envisager certains scénarios
et de fait scénarius
dans la médiia en disant bah tiens
est-ce que là ils vont nous débrancher
les systèmes visas les différents gars
femmes ? Moi, je ne souscris pas. Al,
c'est peut-être je veux peut-être être
une conscience un peu plus apaisée et
une analyse plus froide, mais je pense
pas que ça soit dans l'intérêt des uns
et des autres. On est dans une logique
de dire il y a il y a il y a besoin pour
les États-Unis d'une Europe forte tant
des des nations souveraines mais
également des des des ces plateformes.
Pourquoi les États-Unis ont besoin d'une
Europe forte ?
Parce que il y a il y a un équilibre qui
est en train de se faire avec un monde
qui est en train de se redessiner avec
différents blocs et donc il y a il y a
des une nouvelle réalité. Euh les Évin
d'un vassal.
Non non non non. Les États-Unis ont
besoin d'un d'un allié solide plutôt
qu'un vassal hésitant. Et ça moi j'en
parle volontiers dans mon livre et je je
suis moi-même ce bilational sur cette
ligne de crète sur lequelle on veut me
reprocher les torts des uns des autres
ou les préjugés ou ou les idées
préconçues qu'on peut avoir l'un sur
l'autre. Mais l'enjeu c'est que
pour les services français vous êtes un
américain et pour les services
américains, vous êtes un un agent
français.
Voilà. Voilà. Bon, ça fait un peu
chrinerie un peu mais mais de fait il y
a il y a un peu cette double
justification permanente mais l'enjeu
c'est de rappeler que on peut parfois
avoir une voix salutaire comme les
français sous ville pein rappelons-le
quand même en 2003 lorsqu'il dit mais en
fait c'est une connerie n on vous suivra
pas ne partez pas faire cette guerre en
Irak de la même manière quand Jans ou
Marco Rubio vient à Munich nous rappeler
de manière fraternelle et lucide avec
cette franchise sur bah cet héritage
commun ce lien civilisationnel qu'on a
et qu'on se doit de renforcer et
notamment lutter contre ce qui est en
train de créer un potentiellement un
risque d'effacement civilisationnel qui
serait lié notamment à deux périls qui
sont une immigration massive, des
délires environnementalistes et un
marxisme culturel qui est l'islam
gauchisme.
Non mais on peut pas faire gauchisme. Je
peux
non mais de fait
je te dis je te parlais de marxisme
culturel qui en fait voilà c'est c'est
cette idée de de dissoudre identités
dans un relativisme culturel afin bah de
qu'on soit encore une fois juste des
citoyens d'un grand supermarché européen
sans d'identité nationale. Je juste
juste mis les buz word les les mots clés
un peu balise he faut savoir un truc
c'est sur il y a pas de fachot il y a
pas d'islamo gaucho on se respecte et on
utilise pas des termes qui pourraient
francer les uns les autres on essaie
d'échanger pour comprendre les uns les
autres toutouff
je me demandais quand est-ce qu'on en
qu'on allait en arriver là euh alors
j'ai lu ton bouquin j'ai attendu la page
169 pour faire le grand écart entre
toville etoraura que j'ai beaucoup
rigolé je t'ai trouvé très souple Euh
faut comprendre
comprends pas la blague là. Moi
c'est il faut lire le bouquin pour ça.
Euh
super attaché de presse.
Il y a il y a un truc très intéressant.
Tu vas te demander 5 %.
Il y a il y a un truc très très
intéressant dans le chapitre 7 de ton
bouquin
qui s'appelle
la bataille pour l'âme américaine. Donc
on est vraiment sur le côté guerre
culturelle. Mais pardon. On est
complètement dedans. Et en fait le
discours que tu viens d'entendre, la
rhtorique que tu viens d'entendre islam
gauchisme et tout ça, c'est un truc qui
vient d'un mouvement conservateur qu'on
appelle les paléoconservateurs. C'est un
monsieur qui s'appelle pas de Bucan. Tu
dis si je me si je me
c'est un gars qui a théorisé justement
la guerre civilisationnelle, tous ces
trucs là, tu sais. Tout ce qui empêche
la démocratie, tout ce qui empêche tout
débat, c'est l'appel à l'émotion, c'est
tout genre de truc.
Et j'ai un gros problème avec ça. J'ai
un immense problème avec ça.
Et ben, il va falloir nous expliquer.
Ben déjà d'une part
avant qu'on revienne à la géopolitique,
le paléoconservatisme
déjà d'une part c'est pas français.
Quand tu regardes ce qu'applique Trump
aujourd'hui comme politique, on est
exactement dans ce registre et je pense
qu'en France on a déjà assez de
problèmes comme ça pour se taper en plus
le trumpisme.
Ça c'est mon premier point.
On a déjà le macronisme, c'est ça ?
On a le macronisme, on a LFI, on a on a
on a ce qu'il faut. On est servi en
fait. On est vraiment servi.
Ce mouvement paléo conservateur donc qui
prône carrément une guerre
civilisationnelle. Le truc est
effrayant. On cherche à te [__] la
trouille, on désigne un ennemi, tu vois,
et puis bah tous les autres, ils sont
méchants. Et quand on parle de liberté
d'expression, ce truc est mortifère.
Vraiment mortifère. Tu parlais tout à
l'heure des Twitter files. Excellent
exemple. Effectivement, même s'il y a
pas de preuve que le FBI a directement
demandé à Twitter, non attention a
directement demandé sur ordre de Biden
ou des démocrates de retirer certains
contenus,
on on n pas ce genre de preuve. Par
contre, on est sûr d'un truc, c'est
qu'ils ont signalé des contenus on avec
une petite tête dans le dos. Vous avez
vu ? N enfin là les règles sont pas
respectées. Bah Twitter, qu'est-ce qu'il
faisait ? Il s'exécutait quoi. Tu vois,
c'est une amicale pression en fait. On
va dire
réflexe de Lawrence.
Exactement. Et ce truc a été une
monumentale erreur de la part des
démocrates. Déjà, si c'est vraiment eux
qui sont derrière et si c'est le FBI,
c'est encore une plus belle connerie.
Euh, le retour de bâton est terrible
parce que au nom de la liberté
d'expression aujourd'hui, ce mouvement
euh par conservateur Trump et toute la
clique en fait en tête euh sont en train
de nous servir de la liberté
d'expression pour eux et en même temps
dans le même temps, il te brûlent des
livres.
Pardon ? Ben oui et oui et oui. Donc on
a une liste de 250 mots. Tout ce qui est
de climat machin et tout ça tout ça ça
dégage de la communication et tout ça et
au nom de la liberté d'expression brûlé.
Non mais attends tu conv des images là
fait c'est sérieux sérieux c'est
exactement ça sur
donne-moi un se un seul site Amazon sur
lequel il y a un livre américain qui pas
il y a peut-être des livres qui ont été
interdits dans certaines écoles. Non
plutôt.
Est-ce qu'il faut un accès à la
pornographie dans une bibliothèque
scolaire ? une question
la pornographie, le climat,
enfin des questions de genre et voilà de
générer la disfie de genre. Est-ce que
c'est le lieu ? Est-ce que c'est un
apprentissage ? C'est un temple, un
sanctuaire pour savoir
alors j'ai compris que la liberté en
fait des gens s'arrêteraient à leur
sexualité. Moi ça moi les gens en fait
leur sexualité, j'en ai rien à [__]
ça me perturbe pas. Donc viens viens-en
à l'analyse de la page en question que
je on retourne sur nos sujets. Vas-y.
Donc simplement pour vous dire, je vous
invite en fait à creuser qui est ce
monsieur Paducan et ce qui prône euh et
à vous poser la question si ce truc est
compatible déjà d'une part avec la
République et après avec la démocratie.
Faut bien que vous compreniez un truc,
c'est que la République en fait c'est un
truc qui est super exigeant. Ça existe
des gens qui sont insuiss, qui votent,
qui participent au débat public. Et tu
as Régie de Bri qui disait un truc qui
est vachement intéressant. Il disait que
la démocratie c'est ce qui reste quand
on éteint les lumières de la République.
On n'est pas loin de les éteindre.
Nicolas, tu as été
C'est hyper intéressant parce que c'est
moi mon chapitre préféré de ce livre là
qui traite vraiment d'un sujet très
vertical. Une bataille pour l'âme
américaine et cette guerre culturelle.
On rappelle que c'est un discours qui
est assez vraiment marquant. C'est un
bon exercice d'anglais. C'est le
discours à la convention républicaine de
Pat Bucan en 1991. Il est certes d'un
mouvement paléoconservateur qui fait le
contrepied avec les mouvements
néoconservateurs du bouchisme et donc de
l'affirisme de George Bush. Et donc
Trump lui-même c'est pas celui qui il
est l'héritier de ce mouvement. C'est
pas lui qui a émergé les PL béantes de
l'Amérique. Il a c'est une une
résurgence d'un vieux courant auquel il
a donné une incarnation. Et d'une
certaine manière dans les propos de pap
Bucan qui sont très idéologiques qui
consistent à dire que il y a il y a une
dignité dans tous les Américains. On
n'est pas dans une logique vraiment
hypermatérialiste, mais on est plus dans
une quête civilisationnelle. On peut
trouver des échos à une candidature à
très idéologue à la à la Éric Zemour si
vous voulez mais également à différents
penseurs qui sont venus alimenter le
courant conservateur américain des René
Girard. Enfin, il y a eu des échanges
dans ce dans dans dans cette optique là
qui pour moi sont évidemment on peut
l'approuver ou non, mais on est loin des
enjeux matériel et matérialiste d'un
Manuel Macron qui dit qu'il y a plus de
culture française. C'est au contraire
une réaffirmation de nos identités, de
nos cultures et quand bien même dans le
cas Bucanan qui cert idéologue et qui
n'a pas été élu mais de fait ça il a
porté un peu son nombre en avant avec
l'élection de Trump si vous voulez, il
lui dit bah dans les cours d'école, il y
en a qui sont peut-être pas aussi
éduqués, ils ont pas lu Adam Smith, ils
ont pas lu Edmund Burk mais ce sont des
Américains ordinaires qui n'attendent
pas de miracle et ils ont la même
aspiration que nous. Et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui par rapport aux failles
et aux fractures euh territoriales, nos
failles, la polarisation d'une société
qui est aussi à mon avis est ce que je
dis euh que l'Amérique n'est pas un
modèle mais un miroir, on retrouve ces
mêmes fractures trouvent une résonance.
Donc derrière l'incarnation sera
évidemment pas la même. Dans mon livre
Veratron français, je pose la question,
c'est pas pour une transposition
à l'identique mais une inspiration qui
pour moi euh demande un peu plus de
verticalité à travers une personnalité
euh qui certes joue à visage découvert,
qui a pas de bukanan, mais qui peut
venir alimenter un débat qui s'est
appauvrié de toute forme de doctrine et
de transcendance notamment pour les les
enjeux et le monde en crise qu'on est en
train de vivre actuellement.
Touf, tu veux rebondir ?
Non, pas là-dessus. Je pense que j'ai
dit enfin déjà ce que j'avais à dire.
Euh,
j'ai entendu un truc pareil qui m'a
faitqué à l'instant. Je pense pas que
Macron a dit qu'il n'y avait plus de
culture française. Ça m'étonnerait fort.
Je pense pas que ça soit une situation
une citation de lui. Euh, la culture
française est bien là. Elle est
pregnante. C'est la culture des lumières
et la culture des lumières s'oppose de
toute façon de fait au
paléoconservatisme.
Non, mais la la culture française, c'est
1500 ans d'histoire. C'est des
cathédrales. C'est c'est pas c'est pas
la culture de lumière quoi. C'est
[rires]
Ah
c'est c'est des ajouts. Ça fait de creux
et de boss de pâ lire solaire. C'est ce
qui régit aujourd'hui euh nos relations
sociales. Enfin voilà, c'est quand même
les lumières. C'est
Vous voulez pas décroiser vos jambes
dans l'autre sens les gars ? Parce que
je vous sens un peu si si tu veux. Ah
non non pas du tout. [rires]
Euh c'est pour pas montrer mes ma
doubles braguette tu sais. C'est
on s'en fout.
Ouais. H tu m'as coupé. Je sais plus où
j'en étais du coup. Toi
tu parles de ta braguette mais
Ah non c'est toi qui a coupé. Bon bref.
J'aimerais poser une question à Nicolas.
H
tu connais le Patriot Acte ?
Oui.
C'est quoi le Patriota acte ? Alors, le
Patriot, c'est un dispositif, un
règlement qui a été voté dans la foulée
des attentats du 11 septembre qui a
générer une surveillance à grande
échelle des citoyens américains. Pour
moi, c'est une profonde atteinte aux
libertés publiques, mais qui souscouvert
de nobles intentions comme la lutte
contre le terrorisme a généré cette
surveillance des citoyens américains
qu'il avait rien à se reprocher.
Et
X, j'arrive jamais à le prononcer moouf
XK score
XK score.
X score ça te parle ?
Non.
Stellar Wind, ça te parle ?
C'est je sais pas. Non, c'est vrai c'est
des programmes de surveillance.
Ouais. Ouais. Donc sur les programmes et
de fait la raison c'est de savoir
pourquoi ils se maintiennent encore
aujourd'hui. Même si toute proportion
regardé, si moi je suis contre la
surveillance des citoyens américains,
vous allez me demander si je suis
cohérent ou non par rapport à notamment
des idées de projet des États-Unis qui
visent à faire de la surveillance de
ceux qui feraient des candidatures pour
un visa et se dire bah tiens, si vous
venez aux États-Unis, est-ce que je dois
contrôler votre historique de recherche
sur internet, avoir accès à vos réseaux
sociaux pour filtrer bah vos
provenances, vos idées à la manière d'un
contrôle une palpation de sécurité quand
vous êtes à l'aéroport et un contrôle
biométrique la palpation de sécurité à
Touff aux États-Unis quand on va elle
est un peu plus invasive. Euh je te
reprends tout de suite. Touf si je te
dis le projet indect en Europe.
Index. Ah oui, ça me parle ça. C'est
vieux dis donc.
Mais tu es vieux c'est pour ça que je
t'en parle.
Ouais ouais. Euh c'était quoi déjà ?
Chat contrôle.
Ah chat contrôle. Oui là ça me parle
évidemment. Oui. Bon alors chat
contrôle. Ouais. Alors
alors tous les deux tu veux en parler de
chat contrôle ?
Oui oui je enfin je enfin pour les gens
qui nous regardent, il y a peut-être des
gens qui savent pas ce que c'est. Euh
il y a un besoin de pour les services de
pouvoir intercepter certaines
communications. Or, depuis la
généralisation du chiffrement, de bout
en bout, il a fallu trouver des
techniques pour bah soit ouvrir des
téléphones, soit intercepter des
communications.
Euh, faudra que je refasse tout
l'historique. Je remonte à IOL, en fait,
à l'époque de Sarco. Enfin, voilà qui le
truc est parti en couille complètement
en 2009, en fait. 1984,
c'est c'est parti vraiment en sucette en
2009 où on s'est dit ben ouais caméra de
surveillance machin, on va coller de la
connaissance sociale. Il a il y a eu en
fait un mouvement vraiment sur la
surveillance.
On arrive à chat contrôle. Donc chat
contrôle on a généralisé le chiffrement
aujourd'hui quasiment sur tout internet.
Tous les flux sont chiffrés donc ben on
peut plus les intercepter en clair. On
est vachement bien dans mon été. On
s'est dit
chiffre avec quoi ? Ah bah avec du
chiffrement de bout en bout quand même,
si tu as envie d'intercepter 150
communications et qu'il faut les casser
à la volée, je t'assure que c'est
compliqué. Euh
maintenant, il y a une autre technique.
Quand c'est chiffré de bout en bout, ben
avant que ça parte et une fois que tu
l'as reçu, c'est en clair. Donc les
génies se sont dit qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire ? On va [__] des euh des
mouchards dans les applications type
WhatsApp, signal, machin et tout ça.
Bon, signal a déjà dit qu'il se barrait
euh si c'était le cas. Donc si vous
cherchez des applications de chat
machin, je peux vous recommander Simple
X ou ou session qui sont des trucs assez
correctes et on a des garanti à peu près
sérieuse.
Non non, ils ont pas donné les clés.
Alors faut faut alors
reviens à chat contrôle je t'en
reparlerai après. Bon chat contrôle
justement consiste à placer des
mouchards dans les applications
directement pour pouvoir déchiffrer euh
enfin même pas déchiffrer. Du coup
intercepter les messages une fois
déchiffrés. Euh le truc n'est pas passé.
Ça a été porté par la présidence danoise
si je ne m'abuse. Faudrait vérifier mais
je crois que c'était les Danois. Les
Français étaient tout à fait d'accord
avec ça. Les Allemands étaient un petit
peu plus frileux parce que ils ont quand
même le souvenir que c'est pas cool la
surveillance de masse quoi. Euh
le gros problème c'est que dès que tu
commences en fait à jouer avec ces
outils, dès que tu commences à jouer, on
l'a bien vu avec les caméras de vidéos
surveillance, tu sais la fameuse
expérience pendant les
vidéotection. Oui, la vidéo protection
qui vient casser la gueule au gros
méchant. Voilà.
Euh tout le monde savait, enfin les gens
qui s'intéressent un petit peu à ces
question de surveillance savait que ce
dispositif de test, il était là pour
rester et tu claques pas des millions
dans un dispositif de test pour t'en
débarrasser après. Donc ben
généralisation arrive, j'en arrive à ma
question. Quand on voit le Patriot Act,
quand on voit XK Score, quand on voit
Stellarwin, quand on voit le projet
indect, chat contrôle un peu partout et
là je vous dis si je vous dope ça avec
de l'intelligence artificielle, si je
veux si je vous dope les données déjà
collectées facilement analysables
maintenant,
qu'est-ce que ça donne pour vous notre
société du 21e siècle avec une
transparence
du peuple et une opacité du politique.
Nicolas.
Ouais, effectivement, cette société de
la surveillance, enfin c'est un scénario
chronique mais de plus en plus palpable
et de plus en plus concret euh qui euh
met en place un système de de
surveillance généralisé et qui pour moi
dérive dans un dans un totalitarisme
doux parce que on a peur de la liberté
des citoyens, de leur liberté
d'expression et d'être dans un contrôle
généralisé qui pour moi parce que il y a
un système d'opacité totale peut
déboucher sur des des dérives graves. en
soit qu'il y a des menaces c'està-dire
que pas forcément prendre un crédit
social à la chinoise mais ce genre de
système sur lesquels on peut arriver à
avoir quasiment un arbitraire qui
viendrait s'appliquer plutôt que d'être
un état de droit dans lequel tout le
monde serait égal de enfin de devant la
loi. Je pense que effectivement j'ai
j'ai aucun problème dans une certaine
mesure par rapport à des menaces de la
sécurité nationale à ce qu'on puisse
avoir des règlements d'exception des
états d'urgence. Je demande à ce qu'on
puisse avoir un minimum de transparence
par rapport à ça et de contrôle du
législateur pour éviter qu'on obtienne
des des des dérives qui vont derrière
sous couvert de protection de l'enfance
de mettre au pas les réseaux sociaux et
ça ça a été dit cette semaine par
Jean-Noel Barot ministre des affaires
étrangères c'estàd de vraiment avoir un
contrôle un corsetage de la liberté
d'expression dans un espace qui était
censé être un de liberté qui était
l'internet 2.0 Zé,
il a fallu un snow du côté des
États-Unis pour commencer à se rendre
compte ou à William Binet pour pour
commencer à se rendre compte que il y
avait quand même une dérivée
autoritaire. Avec de l'intelligence
artificielle, les lanceurs d'alerte, ils
vont être cramés avant même d'être
lanceur d'alerte.
Je te vois de l'iné de la tête.
Euh,
j'ai passé une nuit très mouvementée.
Je me
Tu as pensé à moi ?
Pas du tout. [rires]
Euh je me suis intéressé à un truc comme
pas mal de geeks, tu sais. Je m'amuse à
faire tourner les trucs à la mode, open
clow et tout ça, enfin voilà quoi. Puis
en regardant certains trucs,
tu as du Omar chez toi ?
Pas du tout. Euh enfin il est bien isolé
en fait, on va dire au congé dans sa
boîte. Et euh je regardais certains
trucs et [__] et je pardon et je me
suis dit on est foutu en fait euh
vraiment on est foutu. Euh je me suis
rendu compte de
l'asymétrie tu sais qu'il y avait en
fait à l'époque entre les États et des
particuliers
à peu près équipés. Et ben cette
asymétrie, c'est considérablement
réduite
quand on était jeune.
Ouais, c'est et je pense qu'on est pas
prêt à faire face à ce qui arrive.
Qu'est-ce que tu anticipes Touf ? Un
armagueddon clairement un armagueddon.
Tu vois toutes les fuites de données là
qu'il y a eu récemment tu connais la
théorie du du six degrees ?
Tout à fait.
Ouais.
Explique.
Bah l'idée c'est que entre toi et le
pape, il y a pas plus que six personnes
pour aller lui serrer la main. Euh les
fuites de
Non non, il y en a que deux.
Euh oui, c'est vrai quand on te connaît,
toi tu es plus connu que le pap.
Non, pas non. Non. [rires]
Euh je je me suis dit, tu vois, en fait,
je regardais le le les les fites de
données, il y a il y a Bridge Forum qui
a qui a publié en fait toutes les bases
de données sur un CD. Ils ont publié
l'intégralité de leur CDN. Ça veut dire
que là maintenant, c'est plus des trucs
qui sont à vendre, c'est des trucs qui
sont passés dans le domaine public. Le
truc est effrayant.
Si tu reprends la théorie du 6 degrees,
tu vois, tu te dis ben imagine la cible,
c'est plus un tel ou un tel. En fait, tu
tu vas tu vas prendre tu regardes juste
les comptes officiels, les les
pointgouff.fr, les emails qui ont été
compromis
par rebond en fait, tu arrives très vite
à des choses très graves et je pense que
la vague de piratage qu'on a en ce
moment, c'est le début de quelque chose
de beaucoup plus gros et on n'est pas
prêt vraiment, on n'est pas prêt. Tu
doppes ça à Lia, le truc devient mais
complètement effrayant. tu as des accès
en fait à des bah tu peux tu peux enfin
tu peux trouver je pense des accès à à
certains systèmes ultra critiques. Euh
j'ai évoqué pendant un moment l'escada
mais tu vois enfin voilà c'est qu'un
exemple c'est c'est vraiment si tu as
accès vraiment à du à des trucs de
l'armée des machins comme ça on sait pas
ce qui peut se passer derrière ça peut
être ça peut être tu vois du du vol de
de de truc de truc industriel du du
détournement
essayie de voir un peu plus haut quand
même.
Non non je je suis pas un marchand de
peur. J'ai pas envie de [__] la
trouille à tout le monde. Mais quand tu
vois que rien qu'aux États-Unis, avant
d'avoir l'intelligence artificielle, tu
as des mecs qui arrivaient à [__] la
main sur des barrages, le truc est
effrayant avec ce qui arrive aux
journées.
Mais ça même quand on était jeune, on
mettait la main,
on mettait la main sur le le système
énergétique américain. Mais le
dans le nez.
Alors non, moi je me suis pas amusé avec
ce genre de truc. J'ai dû faire un olé
aucuc quelque part au Maghreb. Euh j'ai
dû faire j'ai fait la fac de Magb.
jamais prescription, hein.
Euh, mais enfin c'était c'était ridicule
si tu veux. C'était en gros, c'était un
Cisco qui était ouvert ou une connerie
comme ça. Euh, en ce cas-là, on s'était
fait une interface Brodwin à la faculté
de Taipay. Bon, on avait accès au
système de chauffage, les lumières, on
pouvait allumer les téloches, tu vois.
Enfin, rien de bien méchant, quoi.
Tu as pas fait flamber quelques
imprimantes en Syrie ?
Non, non, pas les imprimantes. Non, moi
je me suis pas attaqué aux imprimantes.
Tu fais que les stations de service en
Russie. [rires]
Non, je ça c'est même pas une station
service, c'est une radio en plus. Euh
qui diffusait qui diffusait dans les
stations services ?
Euh oui. Ah oui oui oui effectivement c
un truc de gaz.
Tu t'es fait aussi les caméras des
voitures de flic ukrainienne. Non.
Ouais ouais. On a on a joué un petit peu
avec ça. On les a prévenu d'ailleurs en
fait à l'époque. Enfin voilà parce que
c'était au tout début de la guerre et
dis les choses par rapport aux fuites de
données, par rapport à si personne
pourra avoir ta cible. H
je te donne un cas concret. Euh il y a
une fédération sportive de Pampan qui
s'est fait ouvrir une
catastrophe. Euh il y a une fédée qui
s'est fait ouvrir et de fédé en fédé, tu
arrives à scanner la population
française et par exemple tu es une
puissance béliqueuse du Wakandar. tu as
décidé d'embêter la France en
neutralisant les deux personnes les plus
importantes d'un sous-marin nucléaire,
c'est-à-dire le Bosco ou le mec qui a
les clés de contact du réacteur. Tu peux
remonter jusqu'à lui avec les fuites de
données qu'il y a maintenant ?
Franchement, je pense Ouais, je je pense
que tu peux le faire en plus ultra
rapidement. C'est ça que
Est-ce que ces personnels Est-ce que ces
personnels sont protégés à ton avis ?
Est-ce que tu penses que notre ministère
de l'intérieur, pas de l'intérieur mais
de la défense, tu te rappelles, tu sais,
c'est ce ministère qui avait une
ministre qui avait un Pegasus sur son
téléphone. Tu penses que on est on a
pris conscience nous en France de ce
danger ou est-ce que il faut qu'on leur
rappelle d'une façon un peu plus
mordante qu'il faut augmenter notre
sécurité ? Alors, je pense qu'il y a une
prise de conscience. Je crois qu'il y a
à peu près h ou neu français 10 qui ont
leur donné qui sont exposés aujourd'hui.
Euh, ne pas en avoir conscience, faut
vraiment pas savoir ce qui se passe dans
le monde. Maintenant, est-ce que les
gens sont capables de se défendre comme
leur demande le gouvernement ? En gros,
c'est super rigolo. Tu as le service
public ou France travail qui se fait
pirater, les mecs, il t'envoient un mail
en disant "Protégez-vous bien." Bah
ouais, mais vous aussi peut-être. Non,
ce serait bien.
Accessoirement nos données aussi. Donc
ça déjà, il y a un vrai problème.
Maintenant, tu te retrouves avec comme
je te disais avec énormément de comptes
officiels. Les mecs vont utilisent quand
même des adresses officielles pour aller
se connecter sur des sur des sites à la
con qui sont piratés
derrière.com.
Mais carrément. Enfin, ce genre de truc
euh c'est problématique. Tu commandes
pas une pizza avec ton adresse du
ministère de l'intérieur. Je sais pas,
c'est la base de la base quoi.
Donc le maillon le plus faible est
toujours le plus crétin en bout de
chaîne. H Mais comment tu crois qu'en
fait ils se sont fait pô justement, il y
a le ministère de l'intérieur he qui
s'est fait qui qui s'est fait qui s'est
qui s'est fait pô euh ils ont eu accès à
des bases de police, des trucs machin
des fichiers, tu vois. Enfin voilà,
500 € euh auprès de la femme de ménage
pour pour brancher une cl USB. Euh même
pas besoin de ça.
Ils ont pris le dernier rentré dans
l'organigramme en lui proposant un peu
de pognon.
Écoute, je sais pas comment ils ont
fait. Toujours est-il que aujourd'hui
par rebond, tu peux avoir accès à des
systèmes critiques. Ces systèmes
critiques, j'ose espérer, j'en suis même
sûr en fait que l'ANC derrière veille au
grain et que il y a quand même pas mal
de de communication qui est faite
vis-à-vis de tous les personnels. Mais
c'est flippant, c'est flippant. Il y a
un moment, tu te demandes s'il faut pas
tout couper et tout refoutre à plat.
Moi, j'en serai là en fait aujourd'hui.
Je vous parlais des des projets de
surveillance, des projets dopés
maintenant à
la militarisation de l'espace urbain,
avec des caméras de vidéosurveillance,
reconnaissance faciale, détection des
attitudes, des démarches, euh suivi des
personnes. Là-dessus, l'entrecroisement
de d'autres fichiers euh ouvert, pas
ouvert ou bientôt ouvert.
notre société. Nicolas, tu es tu es tu
es pas bien vieux, Bluetooth, tu es pas
bien vieux. Vous avez des enfants,
Nicolas a des enfants, toutouf des
enfants. Ça nous laisse quelle société
pour votre progéniture, notre
progéniture, on va vivre à votre sens
dans quel type de société à la chinoise
en mode un peu plus énervé.
Nicolas
encore une fois sur ce modèle à la
chinoise qui est certes un contreexemple
pour ceux qui sont attachés au
libéralistqu
hein le langage corporel les gar langage
non verbal non mais de fait sur ce
système chinois qui permet d'avoir un
système à deux vitesses qui va davantage
contrôler les métropoles plutôt que
l'ensemble d'une grosse civilisation
enfin d'une surveillance généralisée
effectivement c'est c'est une dystopie
vers laquelle on se dit que il y a une
nécessité de de s'élever
plutôt que de laisser passer nos
gouverneurs à l'acte. Est-ce que
évidemment c'est linéaire ? Est-ce qu'il
y a pas manière de reprendre de contrôle
sur le sur le sujet ? Est-ce que c'est
des enjeux nationaux ? Est-ce que ça
nous dépasse ? Est-ce qu'il est pas trop
tard ? Voilà, moi je refuse toute forme
de résignation et de de pilules noires
au cassège pour reprendre une expression
internet mais je pense que il y a la
pilule
elle est Ouais.
Enfin le côté vraiment vivre dans dans
une enfin d'un côté très anxiogène et
euh et voilà sombrer dans le désespoir
parce que on mérite mieux que ça. On a
vu d'autres des phases dans lesquelles
le pays était au bord du gouffre qui
s'est toujours relevé et donc il faut
avoir une part un peu des d'espérance
là-dedans. Euh voilà, moi je je
Touf, tu veux pas faire un peu peur à
Nicolas parce que alors on n jamais trop
on n jamais trop parano, on n jamais
trop [__] Je suis je suis encore une
fois je suis pas un marchand de peur
mais je pense qu'il y a vraiment une
forme de résignation. Euh à partir du
moment où tu fais goûter la surveillance
à un politique, peu importe le bord
duquel il est, il la gardera. Il peut
être de gauche, il peut être de droite.
Et tous les systèmes qu'on est en train
de mettre en place, s'il y a une
alternance politique derrière, les mecs
qui l'ont mis en place, les
socio-démocrates aujourd'hui, ils vont
comprendre que c'était pas bien.
On est en train de laisser des lames de
rasoir qui vont affaiblir nos
démocraties.
Mais complètement. C'est même pas des
lames de rasoir. Enfin, à ce niveau-là,
c'est c'est c'est des katanas, quoi, tu
vois. explique explique.
On a euh il faudrait prendre le le je
peux même pas te prendre l'ensemble
l'ensemble du spectre de la surveillance
en France, mais oui, tu parlais des
caméras avec la détection
comportementale qui va être pluguée à
des IA qui vont elles-mêmes accéder à
des bases de données qu'elles soient
financière, qu'ell soi pour les fichiers
s pour le terrorisme, pour les péos,
pour machin
ton historique Facebook et ton mais
pourquoi pas ton historique Facebook
caramel
[rires]
et ton adresseadou si tu veux, il y a
pas de souci mais Euh
c'est c'est ces bases de données si tu
veux déjà le fait que certaines
existent, je suis pas je suis pas super
chaud mais elles vont tout être elles
vont toutes être interconnecté d'ici
peu. Et ce ce ce truc malheureusement
c'est c'est une demande des politiques
aujourd'hui. Et pourquoi ? Parce qu'ils
ont le même problème que les Chinois.
Enfin c'est ils se rendent compte que
ben la paix sociale en France c'est pas
gagné. Donc ben qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
On va les surveiller puis on va brider
un petit peu plus leur liberté
d'expression. Mais je t'avais déjà parlé
de cette tu vois c'est c'est tout con.
C'est la poussée d'Archimède c'est
[rires]
un iceberg. Tu essayes de l'enfoncer
dans la flotte he mais tu arrives un
petit moment et puis un moment où tu
lâches et puis il te reviens dans la
gueule.
Nico, il fait bien la il fait bien
laisberg hein.
Ouais ouais. Ben, on a une belle
démonstration physique mais qui est
culturelle et qui est sociale et qui se
manifeste avec une volonté en fait de
s'affranchir et de d'avoir cette parole
libre et d'assumer dans l'espace public
médiatique et sur les réseaux que nos
avis bah ils n'ont pas être
criminalisés, ils ont besoin d'être
diffusés, même amplifiés par moment et
ils sont nécessaires pour avoir une
société saine. amplifier, c'est-à-dire
que il faut pas euh qu'on tombe dans des
anathèmes, dans des étiquettes pour
revenir sur le sujet de l'Arcom ou sur
des modulations ou des régulations
algorithmiques encore une fois pour ne
pas dire de censure qui euh nécessite à
ce que on fasse confiance à nos sociétés
démocratiques qui sont matures dans
lequel on puisse admettre ce débat
d'idée plutôt que de vouloir encore une
fois le le cloisonner parce que derrière
c'est c'est l'intérêt du plus grand
nombre qui va se retrouver menacé. Donc
évidemment, je je tombe pas dans la côté
la peur anxiogène, mais c'est vraiment
un combat qui va devoir mobiliser les
gens et à travers différentes euh coup
de sonde, voir même passage à l'acte,
notamment la perquisition des locaux de
X, on peut y voir soit une application
de la loi, soit pour moi une dérive
sécuritaire
pour ne pas dire totalitaire dans la
censure qui doit nous alarmer et qui
doit nous pousser à nous mobiliser et
pas que derrière nos écrans mais dans
l'espace public aussi. Est-ce que vous
avez suivi ce qui se passe en Angleterre
?
Alors moi vaguement
j'ai j'ai envie de te dire que j'ai j'ai
tellement de mal déjà je me concentre
beaucoup sur la politique américaine
pour une bonne et simple raison.
C'est que elle m'impacte beaucoup plus
que la politique même française en ce
moment. C'est dire tu vois vraiment euh
par rapport à mes activités tu vois à
côté. Euh donc oui, effectivement, je
m'intéresse beaucoup plus à la politique
américaine qu'à la qu'à la politique
européenne. C'est peut-être un tort. Euh
maintenant, il y a effectivement une
montée du nationalisme. Il y a une
montée en fait des colères que tu
retrouves partout en Europe. Euh mais
euh c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas si
tu veux euh aujourd'hui qui fait quelque
chose qui fait bloque. On n pas un truc
européen, je je crois pas c'est
international réactionnaire et tout ça.
On a vraiment des trucs qui sont
beaucoup plus diffus avec des
problématiques qui sont très très
locales avec des légendes des fois tu
vois des légendes urbaines locales après
avec des trucs qui sont réellement
passés mais tu as une liberté de la
presse.
Attends quoi ?
Tu as encore une liberté de la presse ?
Je si je pense qu'en Angleterre, tu as
encore une liberté de la presse
qu'on parle l'Angleterre à la Hongrie,
tu vois ce que ce qu'on appelle, ça me
fait rigoler, une une démocratie
libérale
en Hongrie, tu vois. Enfin, en Hongrie,
la liberté d'expression est respectée.
Tu as des journalistes, des organes de
presse et tout ça, mais ils parlent tous
dans le vide. Ils sont juste
invisibilisés. Et puis au fur et à
mesure, ça fait combien de temps qu'il
est là ? Ça fait une quinzaine d'années,
c'est ça ? Je crois que ça fait une
quinzaine d'années qu'il doit être là.
Euh ben sur ce temps
de Orban
euh sur ce temps-là, c'est des proches
de ce monsieur qui ont commencé à
racheter les médias et tout ça. Et
la France là,
alors
j'aime pas faire ce genre de comparatif.
C'est c'est quand même plus dur ce qui
se passe en Hongri. Je suis pas sûr que
tu es spécialement envie d'aller vivre
là-bas. Je sais pas, je
moi ça m'attire pas. C'est pas le pays
qui m'attire. que les les traditions
culinaires angoises sont délicieuses.
Mais probablement enfin voilà,
ça fait des fractures de rétines aussi.
Alors bon, tout ça pour te dire que
c'est pas parce que tu respectes la
liberté d'expression qu'elle est
effective. Tu peux avoir une asymétrie.
Tu as des gens qui sont toujours plus
égaux que les autres. Si tu reprends
avec la ferme des animaux, bah tu as des
animaux plus plus égaux que les autres.
Comme sur les réseaux sociaux, ben tu as
des gens qui vont être plus audibles que
d'autres. Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
fait euh de retirer l'accès
au gamin de 15 ans euh sur les réseaux
sociaux alors que on peut mettre des
filtres parentaux ? Euh
qu'est-ce que En fait ma question
concerne le fait que l'État s'ingère
dans l'éducation des membres
? Moi, j'ai un vieux penchant
libertarien qui veut que j'évite que
l'État vien
que ce vieux penchant
qui vienne s'imisser dans mes affaires.
Et aussi, je pense qu'on se retrouvera
le côté Anard et le côté Trumpis de dire
que
pas un
c'est pas c'est pas à l'état de enfin on
peut pas se décharger sur un état nounou
qui doit nous dire comment nos enfants
doivent être éduqués. Il y a une
responsabilité parentale. J'ai emmené
des enfants dans ce monde. Moi-même, je
passe énormément de temps. Je suis un
activiste numérique. Je suis toujours
derrière les réseaux. mes enfants, ils
n'ont pas l'âge et l'éducation d'être
exposé à ce type de contenu, je les en
tiens à distance. Je peux pas juste me
dire il y a un tel filtre parental parce
que à 15 ans les enfants, moi-même et
vous les premiers, vous saviez bypasser
ça systématiquement. Vous arriviez à on
arrive à contourner. Donc effectivement
ça part d'une intention noble derrière.
Évidemment, on voit jusqu'où ça peut ne
pas aller quoi. Ça peut vraiment prendre
des
On vient de se faire traiter de vieux
mec.
Ah ben de fait tu
as jamais craqué Boomja sur abstrat.
[rires]
Non, mais voilà, concrètement c'est une
noble intention mais l'enfer est pas de
bonnes intentions. Euh mais de fait
considère queon a nous-même cette
responsabilité, on peut pas se décharger
sur un état pour nous dire comment il
faut mettre un fil parental, comment on
doit se laver les mains et porter un
masque. Voyez ce genre de truc un état
nounou, ça m'emmerde
ça. Ça les les les conditions de
sécurité ou sanitaires, ça peut se
discuter.
Non, mais les conditions sanitaires, ça
se discute avec un médecin, pas avec un
politique, on porte-parole du
gouvernement. Ça c'est de moi j'ai des
questions de médical. Euh moi je prends
n'importe quelle politique euh sur mon
état de forme, il y a pas de souci. Mais
si j'ai besoin d'un conseil médicale, je
vais m'adresser à dans le secret du
cabinet médical à mon médecin.
Touf, tu veux ?
Ouais, j'ai moi j'ai deux problèmes avec
cette histoire de d'interdire les
réseaux sociaux à des enfants. Il
croissent tes jambes.
Le mon premier problème euh il est
technique, c'est con hein, mais quand tu
vas demander
si une personne a 15 ans, tu vas pas lui
demander si elle a 15 ans rien qu'àelle.
tu es obligé de vérifier les identités
de tout le monde. Donc tu te retrouves
avec des bases de données énormes
d'identités qui sont piratées comme
Persona récemment, une autre avec plus
d'un milliard de données. Enfin le truc
c'est un carnage mais vraiment c'est un
carnage. Tu peux reprendre mes mes
tweets d'Ail y a un ou de ans en fait où
je disais que ça allait se passer comme
ça. Bah ça s'est passé comme ça.
Effectivement, c'était qu'une question
de temps. Tout le monde le savait.
Le deuxième truc qui m'ennuie un petit
peu plus euh
c'est la motivation politique à poser ce
genre de truc et de gens qui n'avancent
même plus masqués. Quand à Macron qui
dit "On va protéger nos enfants du
djihadisme, on va protéger nos enfants
de parce que c'est son projet. Euh
[rires] on va protéger nos enfants, donc
du djihadisme, du machin et des contenus
d'extrême droite." Il a vraiment dit ça
là. tu sens qu'il y a un glissement
politique et là ça commence à me
déranger parce que ça aurait pu être
d'extrême gauche. Ça peut être les
terroristes écolo de Solland tu vois.
Enfin c'est je peux avoir des
conceptions mais très très étendues de
ce qu'est le terrorisme.
Donc on en revient au fait de qu'il
laisse des lames de rosoir pour les
prochains.
Exactement. Et c'est suicidaire. C'est
suicidaire pour la démocratie.
Mais peut-être que la démocratie est un
épiphénomène.
Non, je pense que les gars sont
persuadés que c'est comme ça que la
démocratie doit fonctionner et tout ça.
Mais le choc est tel avec internet que
c'est vraiment les tu vois le le lapin
pris dans les phards de la bagnole quoi.
Ils savent plus quoi faire en fait
vraiment. Et alors que la solution est
simple, faut tout reposer sur la table.
Et oui, il faut qu'on ait une réflexion
sur notre liberté d'expression qui n'est
pas du tout adaptée à ce qui est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui.
Nicolas
euh effectivement et moi j'ai j'ai
introduit là-dessus sur ces deux
conceptions qui rentrent en conflit et
qui aujourd'hui à l'heure d'Internet ce
premier amendement américain avec cette
conception très très expansive tend à se
répandre et à faire écho à un besoin de
liberté. Si même si derrière il peut y
avoir des législations locales euh du
fait de notre histoire, on doit éviter
de tomber dans une dérive ou un principe
de précaution généralisé et une
surveillance massive qui encore une fois
de par les les liqus enfin les des
fuites massives de données ces derniers
temps sont plus pour le moins assez
préoccupantes. Donc voilà, on se rejoint
là-dessus.
Question internet.
Comment réveiller encore plus de
Français ? Comment agir sur le terrain ?
Qui veut répondre en premier ?
Bah je pense que l'idée du terrain tout
est dans la question ton voisin si tu
pouvais répondre au premier. Vas-y, je
t'en prie. Non, mais honnêtement, c'est
c'est une question là d'ord général he
c'est c'est pas gens se prete pas du
doigt là-dessus, mais c'est
effectivement ça se passe par un
activiste numérique, c'est de se de
s'engager et ça terminera sans doute par
ma conclusion et mon mon conseil pour la
jeune génération, c'est de se mobiliser,
c'est un activisme.
C'est pas fini encore. Non, non, mais
non, mais c'est d'arriver à s'engager
clairement et de sortir alors l'anonyma,
le pseudonyma, très bien, mais également
réinvestir bah différents champs de la
société civile qu'on a un peu abandonné,
que ça soit les associations, les
mairies et une mobilisation à voir et
pas se retrouver dans une situation un
peu nichéenne dans lequelle on est dans
un nilisme total et repé uniquement à la
lumière bleue de nos écrans. Donc, il y
a une volonté. Si vous vous occupez pas
de politique, c'est elle qui va
s'occuper de vous.
Moi je pense qu'il faut qu'il se passe
quelque chose de très grave. Je pense
qu'on prendra conscience que tu vasoler
devant la préfecture, c'est ça ? Pas ça
non mais je
vraiment je commence à être de plus en
plus convaincu qu'il se passera quelque
chose qui fera des morts tout simplement
du genre.
Je sais pas, j'ai pas envie de faire
l'oiseau de mauvais augure et tout ça,
mais ce genre de truc, ça se termine
jamais bien, quoi. Et le problème, c'est
que ça fait des années et des années
qu'on explique que ça va se passer comme
ça. Évidemment, ça se passe comme ça,
quoi. Donc euh ben à un moment, tu te
retrouves avec deux forces qui luttent.
C'est c'est c'est plus possible pour un
politique de faire marche arrière
aujourd'hui s'ils se disent "Ben, on
arrête le DSA, voilà et puis c'est pas
possible. C'est et c'est même pas une
question de perdre la face. C'est une
question que c'est indéfendable
politiquement d'être rentré des années
en fait là-dedans et de se dire à la fin
ben ça marche pas, on va faire
autrement. Et donc je doute que ces
gens-là aujourd'hui mais quel que soit
le bord politique attention moi je suis
persuadé que s'il y a une droite dure
qui arrive en France derrière ça sera
encore pire.
Ça sera encore pire. Ils auront juste
ces outils. On va leur livrer en fait la
dictature clé en main quoi.
Nicolas. Moi je souscris pas entièrement
et pour revenir sur le
entièrement c'est
euh non mais c'està dire que je je vais
me porter en faux là-dessus mais sur le
DSA c'est c'est une évolution lente mais
le le dispositif le règlement il date de
2022. il y a encore une possibilité de
le rééquilibrer. On est en mesure de
demander des définitions et d'attendre
euh qu'est-ce qui qualifie comme étant
un risque systémique euh qui vient
justifier euh ces mesures-là, d'avoir
davantage de transparence, d'avoir de la
proportionnalité aussi pour éviter
d'être un fardeau sur nos propres
plateformes européennes sur lesquelles
on attend de l'innovation, de la
compétitivité. On rappelle que en fait
ce DSA, il vient aujourd'hui sanctionner
ce qu'on n'est pas en mesure de
produire. Euh ces plateformes enfin
elles sont essentiellement américaines
et de fait ça représente un fardeau en
coût de conformité en centaines de
millions de dollars euh qui fait que euh
toute proportion ramené à des
plateformes plus petites, c'est c'est un
coût considérable et qui empêche à nos
propres plateformes d'émerger. Donc
effectivement, moi je je refuse de
considérer que c'est linéaire. Je pense
qu'il peut y avoir une bascule qui peut
être fait. On rappelle juste que jusqu'à
il y a peu en sensiblement au même
moment synchronicité le DSA mais aussi
le rachat de Twitter par Musk euh
c'était complètement enfin il y a une
inversion un peu de de cette tendance où
on voyait on avait dit où il y avait des
abus, une opacité, euh des modérations
et qui étaient vraiment une vraie
entrave à la liberté d'expression sur
Twitter à l'époque. Je dis juste ça
parce que Elon Musk, il a mis 50
milliards de dollars sur la table pour
acheter Twitter. tout le monde lui
prêtait une vie de 3 à 6 mois et qu'il
allait couler la plateforme. Au final,
ça reste encore une fois la place
publique numérique et c'est devenu
incontournable. Même ceux qui le
détestent viennent débattre et
s'écharper dessus. Euh pour tout ça pour
dire que je pense que ils sont tombés
sur un bon client qui va pas juste
encaisser et sortir son carnet chèque
pour verser les amendes pour du DSA. Et
donc je pense qu'il y a il y a un
rééquilibrage qui va se faire et je
pense qu'on peut saluer le fait que Elon
Musk à mon avis va sans doute y aller de
manière assez volontariste tout en et je
veux pour moi isoler certains scénarios
qui n'iront pas vers un débranchement de
l'ensemble des plateformes GFAM sur
l'Europe parce que c'est pas du tout
l'approche constructive mais qu'il
puisse y avoir un bras de fer
institutionnel qui soit mené avec des
gens qui sont des ardents défenseurs de
la liberté d'expression comme Elan Musk
ça me semble davantage lucide rationnel
que une une espèce de guerre nucléaire
ou une guerre froide numérique
touf. Tu veux rebondir juste une seconde
ou je t'envoie sur freedom.goov.
Euh vas-y, envoie-moi sur Freedom.goov.
Allez.
Alors freedom.gov c'est quoi ?
Alors c'est on sait personne ne sait ce
que c'est. En fait aujourd'hui c'est une
page web. Euh derrière il y aura
probablement un portail, on sait pas ce
que c'est. enfin voilà qui est censé te
donner accès aux plateformes non
censurées
et là
comment te dire [rires]
c'est what the fuck donc en gros moi si
je regarde si c'est juste un portail
c'est un proxy c'est tu vois enfin voilà
parce que en fait un VPN s'installe sur
les postes clients et pas sur un site
web euh ça a été vendu comme un VPN
machin bon on va voir ils vont peut-être
proposer un client lourd ou alors une
nouvelle technologie que je connais pas
encore. Pourquoi pas ? Enfin voilà.
Maintenant euh
je suis un vieil internaute. Il y a un
truc que j'aime bien, c'est la
décentralisation.
Quand tu fais passer tout le trafic dans
un co
euh
Thort.
Non, Thor, Tort, c'est vraiment
décentralisé. Mais quand tu fais tout
passer sur un point du temp si tort si
Thort tu as tu as plus de bandes
passantes à un certain nœud, est-ce que
ça concentre pas un peu ce qui passe ?
Ah non, là tu parles en fait d'une
attaque qui consiste en fait à envoyer
des flux pour paralyser certains nœuds
et rediriger le trafic. Oui, c'est une
attaque qui est qui a été utilisée
d'ailleurs par la NSA entre autres.
Certaines ambassades, c'est ça ?
Et certaines ambassades, voilà. Donc
ouais, tu as ce genre de truc maintenant
là c'est c'est plutôt l'architecture, tu
vois, la Benali quoi, à la Tunisie de
Benali. Donc tu as tu as un flux, tu as
un câble et tu fais tout passer
là-dedans. Et donc il faut faire
confiance
au gouvernement américain de Trump pour
faire passer tout le trafic, sachant
qu'ils vont dire c'est chiffré, je te
jure la tête de ma mère et mais ouais
mais non
la main sur le cœur,
tu vois. Enfin voilà, moi il y a aucun
moment où je fous mais une donnée
là-dedans, quoi. C'est rien du tout
quoi. Et on oui mais ils ont déjà nos
données. Bah ouais non c'est débile, ils
ont pas tes chats futurs, tu vois. Par
exemple,
tu préfères les donner à Thierry ? Non,
moi je je voilà, je suis je je vais leur
faire de la pub parce qu'ils font du bon
boulot. J'utilise un VPN qui s'appelle
Nî euh qui est un truc c'est une
fondation suisse derrière, c'est des
gens très sérieux. C'est
Et comme pointe de diamant
euh comment ça un pointe de diamant ?
Chelsea Maning.
Ah oui oui oui tout à fait. Oui euh ou
Chelsea Manning collabore au projet.
On l'embrasse.
Ouais. Et euh c'est c'est ce qu'on
appelle un mixnet, c'est un réseau
anonymisant et voilà c'est le truc que
je recommande. C'est sérieux. Voilà. il
y a
ils nous ont invité à Londres. On a
passé un weekend à Londres avec Chelsea
et et c'était extraordinaire.
D'accord. OK.
Termine sur Freedom.
Donc voilà le fait même que ça soit un
point de centralisation, même si c'est
soit-disant chiffréon, on peut te servir
un certificat SSL qui est qui est qui
qui est légitime mais sur lequel il peut
faire n'importe quelle saloperie. C'est
le dernier des trucs à faire d'utiliser
ce trucl. Mais vraiment je peux vous
recommander une chose, c'est de rester
loin de ce machinl. Voilà. Nicolas,
est-ce que tu comprends son point de vue
? Je le comprends et d'ailleurs euh bah
je le je remercie parce que c'est un peu
l'origine un peu de de l'interaction par
Twitter interposé et qui mérite de
peut-être de poser ce qu'on sait de ce
qu'on ignore de ce portail
gouvernemental qui est développé par le
secrétariat d'État américain qui vise à
répondre à une attente à la fois
européenne mais sans doute
potentiellement iranienne ou chinoise
par rapport à des contenus qui sont
modérés dans des pays et euh sous
prétexte de modération régulation. Et
donc à ce stade, ça reste que une page
web avec euh des annonces qui ont été
faites par Reuters, mais il y a pas
encore de services qui sont proposé. Euh
derrière ce cette plateforme, il y a des
gens qui ont travaillé avec Musk dans le
DOJE, donc le département de
l'efficacité gouvernementale qui en tout
cas en tout état de cause, combien même
on n pas vu ce qu'il y avait sous le
capot à l'heure actuelle, eux disent que
l'algorithme sera open source. Enfin, tu
vois, le code sera open source. Il y a
une volonté de transparence par rapport
à ça. Il y aura pas de bac d'or comme on
dit qui permettent porte dérober
de porte dérober. Voilà. Merci.
Il y a pas besoin de bacdor
euh et qui à mon avis au-delà de la
simple faisabilité technique qui peut
mettre nous mettre en doute, on peut
rester dubitatif et a juste raison parce
que si on aimait la situation actuelle,
on se dire "Bah tiens, les VPN ça
s'installe sur un poste de travail, bon
c'est un client lourd." Si derrière il y
a une innovation un peu plus disruptive,
euh ce qu'on peut imaginer, bah
peut-être qu'on a on a une innovation de
rupture qui nous fait rentrer dans un
dans une nouvelle approche de
consommation et d'exposition des
contenus. Après, ça pose pas la question
de est-ce que je suis à l'aise de
partager mes données, mais je compense
encore une fois que ça sera consenti le
faire. Derrière, je pense aussi et moi
je je repensais à cette question là
parce que à ce stade, on est en train de
gloser, de spéculer par rapport à une
page qui est plutôt bien ficelée avec
une animation en gif. Bon, pourquoi pas
? Est-ce que vous vous souvenez en 1957
du Sputnck le Sputnic derrière c'est
devenu une référence de moment Spoutnic.
Les Russes, l'Union soviétique étaiit
les premiers à avoir envoyé un
satellite, le Spoutnik et ça avait
montré aux Américains le retard qu'ils
avaient accumulé en la matière en
matière de recherche spatiale et d'envoi
de satellite. À la suite de ça, ils ont
appuyé sur le turbo et ils ont massifié
leur investissement dans cette dans
cette sphère là. Je finis la parenthèse
historique pour dire que peut-être ce à
quoi on est en train d'assister, c'est
un effet spoutnique inversé où désormais
ce portail ou cette annonce d'un
livrable éventuel sur lequel il y a pas
absolument aucune garantie, c'est pas un
service commercial, service proposé par
le secrétariat d'État, il y a peut-être
une logique de soft power et d'influence
et de guerre culturelle de se dire bah
tiens, nous aux États-Unis, on a cette
capacité à offrir cet espace de liberté
et ce pourquoi la vocation originelle de
l'internet, un courant dans lequel il y
a un foisonnement et ce fameux place
commune, marché d'idées qui qui
s'exprimeraiit. Donc encore une fois, je
ne veux pas juger sur l'aspect technique
mais plus sur l'aspect philosophique et
de la conception de la liberté
d'expression auquel on va assister. Et
je rappelle parce qu'il y avait des
doutes là-dessus que sur les annonces
qui ont été faites à ce jour, il y a de
au même titre de ce qui avait été fait
durant le DODE, une vraie transparence
de Dodge, donc l'initiative portée par
Musk et sa petite équipe visant à à
assignir les finances publiques en
coupant de la fraude, de la Gabgie, des
abus et voilà juste des pertes de
productivité.
Moi moi il y a il y a je j'aiqué sur
quelque chose que vient de dire Nicolas
qui qui me fait délirer. Tu viens
d'employer encore une fois le mot guerre
culturelle.
Rend compte en fait de la pirouette. On
t'offre un outil pour te mener une
guerre culturelle. Je sais pas, je
trouve ça bizarre. Je j'ai un problème
avec ça conceptuellement.
C'est quoi ? C'est bombarder pour la
paix.
C'est un petit peu ça. Enfin non mais le
coup je t'offre un outil pour te mener
une guerre culturelle qui ça marche pas.
C'est cadeau.
Je pense qu'il faut qu'on revienne sur
le principe. Qu'est-ce qui est pourquoi
en quoi en réponse à quoi est-ce que ça
vient ? Il y a des entraves et on a été
conscient pour poser les diagnostics. On
a nos
que ça soit en France, que ça soit en
Europe, mais également là vous avez un
peuple en Iran ou même en Ukraine sur
lesquels il y a il y a pas de bon c'est
c'est un autre sujet mais bon sur quand
même sur l'Iran, ils ont brouillé toutes
les communications. Même Starlink ne
passait plus. Pas d'ingérence
culturelle.
Oui, bien sûr, mais derrière cette
ingérence, c'est toute voix discordante
qui va être muselée, criminalisée et euh
complètement étouffé euh figurativement.
Donc je pense que
mais encore une fois euh on pourrait
dire euh Elen Musk pour revenir à son
sur sur X pour parler de l'existant
plutôt que du prospectif sur freedom.com
X il dit bah tiens ça va devenir la
place publique numérique je suis pour un
foisonnement d'idée et on est d'accord
ou pas mais ma plateforme est disponible
et de fait il y a des gens qui à
longueur de de tweet con pu et vomist
Trump Musk et qui vous voulez c'est pas
une plateforme conservatrice.
D'ailleurs, il y a je pense une forte
polarisation sur cette plateforme là qui
fait que c'est pas à sens unique, c'est
un principe qu'on défend plutôt qu'un
courant d'idée. C'est un principe et pas
des personnes. Donc je pense que dans le
sens la bataille culturelle, c'est
indépendamment du du côté du prisme du
lequel vous vous situez. C'est plutôt
pour faire face à des menaces qui nous
viendraient d'en haut. Alors, ça fait
peut-être un peu conspite de dire ça,
mais je m'appuie encore une fois sur des
diagnostics sur lesquels on était
d'accord de poser en disant que il y a
clairement une musique de fond qui dit
que sous couvert de la protection de
l'enfance, sous la couvert de menaces
d'ingérence étrangère, on souhaite
qu'asser la liberté d'expression et donc
ça permet et pas dans une logique s
power de droite, tu pourrais dire c'est
une guerre culturelle gauchisante,
pirate ou antitrumpiste, mais qui
pourrait s'opérer de manière détournée.
Alors encore une fois, il y a une
question légale et philosophique à
avoir. C'est pas à moi de trancher
là-dessus, de se dire "Bah tiens, est-ce
que c'est pas une manière de contourner
les lois d'un pays ? Est-ce que d'un
point de vue légaliste, moi je suis pas
docteur en droit constit, il appartient
à chacun d'avoir ses ses réflexions en
son fort intérieur et face à sa
conscience et face aux lois de son pays.
Mais encore une fois, je pense pas que
ça soit destiné. C'est pas un kit de
survie ou une arme terme que je
n'emploie pas et que je n'accepte pas
pour mener une guerre culturelle
conservatrice ou voilà les fameuses
lumières sombres comme on voudrait nous
mettre en avant. une espèce de
contreévolution pour moi c'est un moyen
pour diffuser des idées et quel que soit
leur origine leur appartenance ou leur
affiliation politique
touf
bah moi j'ai pas l'habitude d'amener mon
sable à la plage. Du coup, j'ai envie de
te dire que en Europe, on a nos outils
déjà qui fonctionnent très bien. Enfin
voilà, qui nous permettent d'accéder à
des contenus non censuré. C'est des
contenus.
Ouais. Ils interdisent les VPN.
Non, ils interdiront pas les VPN. Ça n'a
aucun sens d'interdire les VPN. Tu te
rends pas compte du nombre d'entreprises
qui [rires] ont besoin. Si tu as envie
d'interdire les VPN, faut faut les
bloquer au niveau protocolaire. Tu si tu
fais ça, en fait, bah les banques, elles
s'arrêtent, tu vois, toutes les
entreprises, elles s'arrêtent. Donc non,
ils vont pas interdire les VPN. Ils vont
te demander éventuellement ta carte
d'identité pour mais tu seras pas obligé
de passer par des VPN qui te les
demandent. C'est il y a aucun moment en
fait. Ils vont ils vont ils vont ils
vont ils vont faire quoi ? Ils vont
taper sur les gros ils vont choper Nord
VPN, machin VPN, bidu VPN, tous les
trucs qui font la pub à la télé, qui
font de la pub partout. V taper dessus.
Ben non mais il y a plus de tout VPN.
J'utilise un autre. Enfin voilà, je je
il y a il y a un truc auquel je
participe euh que je veux pas nommer
pour plein de raisons et Yanim que
j'utilise en fait en ha
ils pourront pas euh réguler tous les
VPN, c'est pas possible si tu as envie
de les bloquer. Ce que je te dis, il
faut faire ça au niveau protocolaire,
question internet
au niveau des FAI.
Question internet, fournisseur d'accès
internet.
Question internet. Le fonctionnement du
DSA Digital Service Act est cadncé entre
parenthèses réunion confidentielle
SMS qui s'auto détruisent ça c'est par
rapport au message sur signal fermer la
parenthèse. Avez-vous quelques chiffres
sur le niveau de censure ou
d'invisibilisation sur les thèmes
lesmovisé ? Alors non, et c'est en fait
le gros problème. Normalement euh il y a
encore un volet de transparence dans le
DSA, mais ça viendra peut-être dans un
autre temps. J'ai l'impression que c'est
pas le truc qui les excite le plus en ce
moment. Ils sont en train d'essayer de
parer à une urgence. Euh
Nicolas, il y a combien de zéro à 1
milliard ?
Ne9.
Bien Touf, il a répondu pour toi. Tu es
pas obligé de répondre. Question
internet que je prends et que je
découvre avec vous. Ne pensez-vous pas
voir les prémises de la fin du
capitalisme/libéralisme
deux phases d'une même pièce référence à
Michaonnement
de la population.
Moi je pense pas.
Attends, il t'a demandé à Nicolas si tu
pouvais répondre en premier. Vas-y vas-y
vas-y. [rires]
Non non franchement je pense pas. Alors,
on est on est peut-être un petit peu
désillusionné de cette ce qu'on appelait
la mondialisation heureuse et qui a
offert la Rosebelt en fait à Trump.
Mais
je ne pense pas qu'on soit prêt à
trouver autre chose en fait déjà tout de
suite. Un changement de régime, ça peut
être soit très brutal et directement en
dictature, soit on fait un truc plus
intelligent et ça demande du temps et de
la réflexion.
Moi, je pense qu'on est déjà arrivé dans
un nouveau monde qui en fait la
résurgence d'un ancien et une société
postlibérale parce qu'on a vu que ce
libéralisme à outrance
va créer en fait des mots dans nos
sociétés enfin notamment occidentales
dans lesquels on a été les premiers à
partir de cette fameuse mondialisation
heureuse. C'est marrant qu'on parle de
Michia parce que je le convoque moi-même
comme référence et on m'a fait le procès
de dire tiens vous êtes un gros droitard
et vous faites référence à des auteurs
de gauche. De fait ça montre que je suis
pas trop sectire parce que je
m'interroge à des concepts.
Peut-être que les mecs qui te qualifient
sont à bouffer du foin
sans doute mais c'est surtout tout pour
montrer le parallèle qu'on avait entre
la révolte des élites de Christopher L
un penseur américain et le libéralisme
libertaire de Micher. Et donc ça je
pensais que c'est pour montrer qu'il y a
des des idées qui traversent
l'Atlantique. De manière plus concrète,
je pense qu'une société postlibérale,
c'est un mouvement qui s'est déjà amorcé
et qui à plus forte raison va être
amplifié, accéléré au vu de cette
nouvelle révolution qu'on a été en train
de traverser qui est celle de l'IA.
Alors, peut-être que c'est des poncifs,
mais on voit que la la valeur travail,
les capitaux vont vont vont circuler
différemment avec potentiellement euh
moins de besoin d'avoir de la main
d'œuvre qui serait externalisée dans des
pays à Bakou et donc qui justifierait de
fait du protectionnisme raisonné à
l'image de ce qu' est en train de faire
Donald Trump aux États-Unis sous son
impulsion mais qui date pas que de lui
et qui va lui survivre. Euh vous
comprenez bien quand moi je parle de
Donald Trump, je le dis parce que c'est
le président à la Maison Blanche.
Moi j'ai déjà été à l'investiture, j'ai
déjà été à des meetings.
Non hélas non. J'ai pas encore fait de
golf non plus avec lui.
Tu as fait la bise à sa femme, j'espère.
[rires]
Bah en tout cas, j'ai vu son
documentaire et je vous le recommande et
il a pas été diffusé en France.
Tu es souverainiste toi ?
Euh oui oui bien sûr mais je suis
attaché. Moi je
quand tu vois Trump qui est en train de
prendre le Grenland de Grewood Force, ça
te fait ça te fait raisonner, pas
raisonner ? Tu es critique ? Tu es pas
critique ? Je suis critique du fait que
les Européens n'ont rien fait pour
développer le Groenland au point où ils
auraient pu demander leur indépendance
et ils se serait trouvé à la prédation
de de la Chine ou de la Russie. Euh je
pense que on n' pas du tout anticipé les
menaces qu'il y avaient tout autour du
cercle polaire indépendamment du
Groenland. C'est qui ont ?
Bah ont les Européens euh et on a eu
besoin que un bon Donald nous réveille
en disant "Bah tiens, on a besoin de ça
pour notre sécurité nationale pour
sortir de la dépendance stratégique
vis-à-vis des terres chinoises, de
l'uranium
entre autres et voilà et pour aussi bah
bénéficier d'une protection aussi dans
cette zone d'Atlantique nord. Donc
effectivement moi-même je le vis pas
bien mais encore une fois il y a pas eu
de gré ou de force. Il y a pas eu de
force, rappelons-le, hein, contrairement
à ce qu'on nous annonçait à longueur
d'antenne. Maintenant, de manière plus
spécifique, si Macron se fait tenser
pour ses lunettes de soleil, ça
m'impacte pas dans mon fort intérieur de
patriote. J'ai des amis qui sont
tellement anti-américains qui aiment pas
eu qui d'ailleurs détestent Macron mais
qui n'aiment pas qu'on qu'on vienne à
travers la figure de Macron sans prendre
à la figure de la France. Euh moi je
sais faire un peu preuve de
distanciation entre les gouvernements et
nos gouvernants et nos nations qui
lattent non déplais à certains au-delà
des lumières et depuis euh depuis aussi
longtemps que que l'UTAS est créé.
Touf. Alors, je veux bien que le Trump
soit pas très familiarisé avec ça, mais
on n'envahit pas le voisin, on menace
pas le voisin. Euh quand sa cour suprême
lui dit "Tu as pas le droit de faire ça"
et ben, on tape pas sur sa femme. Je
sais pas,
il y a des trucs comme ça, enfin voilà,
on punit pas le monde entier parce que
ta cour suprême, elle t'a dit "Non, faut
c'est pas bien ce que tu fais." C'est et
moi c'est ce genre de truc qui me qui me
bute un petit peu avec Trump. Euh alors
après il y en a plein d'autres mais euh
cette histoire de Groenland assez
rigolote. Non, j'ai pas rencontré Trump
et je t'avoue que j'enlève pas la nuit
non plus. J'enlève pas la nuit non plus
et je regarderai pas son film.
D'ailleurs, il suffit de voir les
chiffres pour te rendre compte. Bah il
s'appelle Mélania. Alors c'est très
intéressant. Il a été produit par un
monsieur qui apparaît d'ailleurs dans
les dossiers.
Ouais. On a failli recevoir Mélania
d'ailleurs
mais il fallait qu'on allonge 100000
balles qu'on pas le budget. Le le le
[rires] monsieur qui a produit qui a
produit son film euh était un bon copain
d'Epstein. Il figure en bonne place
apparemment dans les fichiers Epstein.
Ça c'est assez rigolo en fait de
retomber là-dessus. Je me rappelle plus,
c'est un nom en R à la fin.
Euh le truc qui est très rigolo, c'est
que euh tu te retrouves, je sais même
plus où je voulais en venir en fait. Je
te je parlais du Groenland, Mélania,
enfin voilà, je je Oui, c'est ça.
Alors, un, on nenvaille pas le voisin.
De le documentaire je il sera diffusé
probablement sur Amazon c'est ça ? Enfin
voilà. Euh parce qu'évidemment il a été
financé également par Amazon. Faut bien
comprendre que tout ce qui sort des
productions de Trump n'est jamais
financé par Trump. [rires] C'est une
constante aussi.
Bah le contribuable le contribuable de
reconnaissant. Bah le contribuable
heureusement je sais pas s'il est ultra
reconnaissant pour d'autres trucs. Tu
vois par exemple sur Medicad le Trump on
l'attend toujours, tu vois. Enfin voilà
il a quand même su créer les aides
médicales à 17 millions de personnes. Tu
vois tu peux vendre des résultats
économiques extraordinaires comme il l'a
fait. Euh les chiffres sont là. La
croissance au 3e trimestre c'était 44.
Elle est passée à 14.
C'est euh c'est méchant. C'est euh c'est
une claque.
Il a construit une autre de la Maison
Blanche grâce aux amendes qu'il a eu.
Moi grâce au aux compensations. On sait
même pas. Il fera probablement il fera
probablement une rallonge, t'inquiète
pas.
Euh
après je moi je
peut-être un mini golf à l'intérieur de
la salle de balle. Écoute, je je suis
pas je pas architecte, j'en sais rien.
Enfin voilà, on s'écarte beaucoup
euh
Grenland souveraineté.
Comment ?
Groenland souveraineté.
Ouais. Groenland souveraineté. Alors
bon, c'est pareil. Est-ce qu'on a les
moyens est-ce qu'on a les moyens de nos
ambitions ? Pardon mais c'est ça le le
nœud du sujet. Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
pour garantir un verrou Arctique alors
que ça va être une zone stratégique au
moins aussi importante qu'elle a été le
canal de Panama au 19e canal de Suè au
20e ?
Je te trouve ingrat Nicolas qu'on a fait
on a envoyé Solen Royal ambassadrice
d'épaules.
Tu es un gras Nicolas. Les
les les Américains peuvent déjà faire ce
qu'ils veulent Groenland. Ils peuvent
déjà faire ce qu'ils veulent. Ils ont
des bases machin, il y avait beaucoup de
monde à une époque, ils ont retiré du
monde parce que ça les intéressait plus.
Ils peuvent très bien revenir. Mais
pourquoi revendiquer carrément la terre
quoi ? C'est c'est pas une terre que tu
achètes, il y a un peuple dessus quoi.
C'est tu vois ça proposé. D'ailleurs,
il y a il y a il y a un épisode que vous
avez peut-être suivi qui m'a beaucoup
fait rire personnellement, c'est cette
histoire. Il y a Non, non, non. Il y a
un marin qui est tombé malade dans un
sous-marin qui croisait au large des ea
des eaughenlandaises. Il avait
mangé une hîre
probablement. Il avait mangé une h pas
fraîche et il a été secouru par la
marine danoise.
Et Trump
pour faire diversion de je sais pas
quoi, j'ai pas compris le délire quoi,
explique qu'il a qu'il va envoyer un
bateau hôpital. Sauf que les deux
bateaux hôpitaux qu'ont les États-Unis
étaient en calèche parce qu'ils étaient
en réparation.
C'est quoi ta source ?
Je peux la trouver très facilement. Il y
a
Mika, c'est ça ?
Comment ?
Mika Meret.
Non non, pas du tout. Enfin, c'est c'est
ça a été repris dans toute la presse.
C'est un truc qui est ultra aisément
trouvable.
Euh peu importe. Donc il y a aucun
bateau évidemment hôpital qui est parti
au Groenland. Les Groenlandais lui ont
répondu "Non, mais vous inquiétez pas,
ça va, on a un système de santé qui est
gratuit. On va le chouchouter votre gars
quoi."
Nicolas,
c'est Nicolas qui paye le système de
santé qui est gratuit. C'est encore,
c'est une tarte à la crème, c'est une
fiction, ça ne marche pas. Il y a rien
qui a été fait pour le Grenland. Il y a
juste un aéroport qui a été développé.
Vas-y, mais c'est ton argument. Mais de
fait Ah mais de fait ça ça peut être
intéressant pour nous parce que
indépendamment de la situation des gros
demandé, ça peut nous poser des
questions par rapport à notre propre
système de santé et de le rentrer dans
cette logique du tout est gratuit, c'est
l'état qui pai. Voilà, revenons sur les
fondamentaux, c'est Nicolas qui pai.
Donc ça mis de côté évidemment.
Combien Nicolas ?
Bah moi je suis à mon compte, je suis
payé par personne. Je vis
combien d'impôts ? Bah là, j'ai avant
j'étais salarié et de fait euh voilà, je
suis dans une tranche dans la position
je suis dans une classe moyenne
inférieure par parce que je suis dans
une phase entrepreneuriale mais euh
combien je paye euh voilà de fait si
vous voulez tout savoir en tant que
binational, en tant qu'américain, je
déclare les revenus que je gagne et donc
j'en paye pas aux États-Unis, mais je
dois quand même donner la situation des
comptes. Chose contre lequel je lutte
évidemment parce que ça fait preuve
d'une extraterrité. C'est un des gains
qu'on a obtenu auprès de Trump lors de
sa de sa campagne en fin de course, il a
proposé ça. Pour l'instant, on n'y est
pas encore. Je rappelle que euh une
formation politique et je vais quand
même la citer, le NFP à l'époque avait
fait cette proposition qu'on mette en
place cette taxation par la citoyenneté
et non par la résidence. Euh évidemment,
c'est une aberration et c'est un c'est
un système une machine à gaz, même si la
question philosophique peut se poser euh
bon peut-être je leur donne raison, mais
à vous de juger à la communauté juger.
Si
tu as deux passeports,
j'ai deux passeports, j'en ai même un
troisème.
Et le troisème c'est le
canadien.
Si on te demandait d'en garder qu'un.
Ah ouais mais déjà est-ce que vous avez
financé ? Mais non mais je pense que ça
va au-delà d'une simple de simple
papier. Moi je suis pas un français en
américain de papier. C'est de toute
manière est-ce que j'aurais moins est-ce
que je serais moins taxé d'allégance
avec d'un côté ou de l'autre ? Si je
renonçais à un des passeports, moi
voilà, sans faire état de mes de mes
états de service, mais j'ai servi dans
l'armée française, je suis officier de
réserve. Euh j'ai prêté
chez les verts ou chez les bleus ?
Oui, non plutôt chez les bleus. Enfin
non, pardon, chez les kaki et après avec
un bret bleu et ensuite un bret noir.
Mais la question c'est effectivement
voilà, j'ai j'ai deux identités qui se
renforcent et qui se j'ai jamais été
amené à choisir entre ma mon père et ma
mère sur ce sujet-là. Donc
s'il y avait la guerre entre les
États-Unis, l'Europe et donc la France,
moi je veux pas rentrer dans ce genre de
politique fiction.
Et si
et si et si Non mais est-ce que tu
devrais prendre prendre une arme et
toi-même aller tirer sur des gens d'un
pays que tu aimes dans sa culture ?
Nous on aime tout le monde donc on ira
tirer sur personne.
Non mais voilà, c'est une vraie
question. C'est une vraie question.
Encore une fois pour moi ça relève de la
poétique fiction et tu vois c'est
contre s'ils viennent chez moi, ça reste
des ça. Moi moi non plus. Alors moi il y
a tu vois et encore une fois un état ty
pourrait être américain, il pourrait
être français aussi he du jour au
lendemain. On sait jamais cette bascule
cette bascule autoritaire et d'ailleurs
les États-Unis en connaissent quelque
chose. Ils ont obtenu leur premier
amendement et leur deuxième amendement
en battant contre la Couron d'Angleterre
qui était devenue un état tyrannique qui
leur avait imposé une taxation sans
représentation et qui à la force d'un
d'un immense sacrifice et bah d'une
mobilisation et d'ailleurs grâce à un
déploiement et un comptage français la
faillette Rechambeau et j'en passe la
royauté à l'époque a permis à ce que
voilà les le peuple américain obtienne
sa souveraineté et son indépendance donc
j'en termine par là évidemment
évidemment il peut y avoir des
hostilités entre nation mais également
Pour revenir au sujet qui était pas ma
ma thèse mais qui était celle du
discours de Vance, il faut se prémunir
des ennemis de l'intérieur.
Bah écoute, moi en tant que patriote pas
spécialement marqué politiquement, ça me
choque qu'un vence vienne me donner des
des leçons de liberté d'expression.
C'est c'est pas son rôle.
Je suis désolé, c'est pas son rôle,
c'est une inérence. Attends, attends, si
c'est un ami qui vient de voir, même
s'il le fait à l'américaine
et qui dit "Bon, ça déconne."
Oui, mais mon ami,
tu l'écoutes ou tu l'écoutes pas ?
Mais mon ami, je le vois et puis on boit
une bière ensemble, tu vois. On en
discute. On fait pas ça sur une
conférence
et tu mangé une pizza dans le 77.
Non, mais c'est pas le problème. Mettons
euh là, le mec, il est en représentation
officielle, il arrive sur le vieux
continent donner des libertés, des des
leçons de liberté d'expression. C'est le
truc est complètement what the fuck. Tu
peux le retourner dans le dans tous les
sens quand tu es patriote. Faut faire
preuve de schizophrénie pour trouver que
le le truc est normal quoi. Tu vois, je
comprends pas.
Tu as pas pris ça comme un électrochoc ?
Un électrochoc de quoi ? De ce mec ?
Mais pas du tout. C'est V pour moi est
totalement insignifiant. Il ne me
représente pas.
C'est encore une autre histoire. La
dernière fois que j'ai foutu les pieds
aux États-Unis il y a très longtemps. Je
devais avoir 20 ans. Donc ouais. [__]
c'est super vieux. Bon, ça ça a presque
fait fouiller les cavités ou pas ?
Alors non, mais euh pour des raisons
autres, je sais que je ne peux pas y
retourner, ça me pose problème.
Mais c'est quoi les raisons ?
Les raisons, c'est que à partir de 2009,
j'ai fricoté avec des gens qui
s'appellent Wikileak
que j'ai comme beaucoup de gens monté
des nœuds, des trucs comme ça, mais il
se trouve que j'étais probablement un
petit peu plus visible que d'autres
personnes.
Voilà,
on va essayer.
J'ai pas spécialement envie, vraiment.
J'ai pas spécialement envie et je
t'avoue que l'Amérique de Trump me fait
vraiment pas rêver. Et l'Amérique des
Américains,
bah beaucoup plus. Je connais
l'Oklahoma, je connais la Californie,
j'ai beaucoup apprécié les deux.
Ça veut dire quoi ? Je connais la
Californie,
je connais bien San Diego, je connais
bien Coronado, je connais bien San
Francisco. Voilà, j'ai été plusieurs
fois là-bas.
Tu as été visiter le petit cimetière des
animaux de compagnie en face du Golden
Gate ? Non, pas du tout. Ça, je l'ai pas
vu.
Tu as visité la forêt d'ecalyptus
arc-en-ciel ? Ah oui
Nicolas.
Oui effectivement JV ne nous représente
pas mais je pense qu'on a besoin de
franchise plutôt que de flatterie et que
on a été d'accord jusqu'à présent sur
les constats et sur les diagnostics et
que là lui-même vient dans une position
de légitimité parce que c'est une
situation qu'ils ont eux-mêmes traversé
aux États-Unis. On rappelle que la
justice, elle a été politisée, qu'il y a
des voies conservatrices qui ont été
censurées, que il y a eu également une
très grave crise migratoire et tout ça
vient porter atteinte à cette cette
enfin c'est cette communauté de destin
qui est une nation. Et donc
effectivement ça peut ça peut nous
c'était vraiment un électrochoc. Il y a
pas allé de mains morte euh mais encore
une fois c'est pas parce que on n'est
pas d'accord avec le messager qu'il faut
refuser le message.
Non Nicolas
attends il t'a donné la parole ou pas ?
Je j'é je passe la bon.
Tu es d'accord avec moi que niveau
instrumentalisation de la justice, Trump
est en train de battre des records. Là,
il y a pas un moment, il y a il y a pas
un moment, bah c'est simple, euh
chaque truc qui lui plaît pas, par
exemple l'histoire de Jimmy Kimmel
machin, enfin voilà. Bon déjà liberté
d'expression, tu vois, on va attaquer
des humoristes. Euh lancer des
procédures à tour de bras euh que ça
soit contre la presse machin, en faisant
carrément des listes et en demandant à
Pam Bondi qui s'exécute tout de suite.
Il fallait voir l'audition de Pam Bondi
devant le Pam Bondi pour ceux qui savent
pas
c'est la mini
la mini de la justice ancienne procureur
de Floride très très trumpiste pas
forcément la meilleure de l'équipe et de
fait dans sa réaction voilà enfin c'est
à voir son langage non verbal et sa
tenue elle était pas exemplaire
c'est enfin c'est une l'image que ça
donne de la démocratie américaine et de
la séparation des pouvoirs est terrible
terrible
bande de yes alors elle c'est
probablement la plus compétente quand tu
prends l'ensemble en fait des gens
autour parce qu'on se retrouve quand
même avec un ambassadeur qui est qui est
une sorte de Stéphane Plaza local quoi,
tu vois. Enfin voilà,
laisse Stéphane tranquille.
Oui mais enfin le seul truc qui
différencie en fait c'est le nombre de
condamnations quoi. Tu vois il y en a un
qui est fraudeur fiscal, l'autre qui
tape sur sa femme quoi. Bah oui mais on
en est là.
On connaît pas le personnage donc
bah enfin ça c'est facile en plus parce
que c'est il se trouve que c'est le papa
du mari de la fille de Trump tu vois.
pas il y a toujours un lien familial, un
lien de pognon. Il y a toujours un truc
comme ça en fait dans les équipes de
Trump. C'est c'est systématique.
Peu importe la qualification, il lui
faut des yes man.
Non mais on a entendu des accusations
graves pas sustentées. Moi je rappelle
juste que non mais là tu dis il y a une
instrumentalisation de la justice la
presse avec des procès. Mais non mais
j'ai entendu une série de listes à la
préver mais il y a encore une fois pas
d'accusation. Il y a eu Jamie Kimmel qui
est pas à la demande de Trump mais à la
demande des affiliés de la chaîne pour
des propos qui étaient absolument
outrageux vis-à-vis et de la diffamation
qui était au moment de l'assassinat
politique de Charlie Kirk en direct par
quelqu'un de la mouvance ultra gauche.
Il vient dire en fait celui qui a tué
Charlie Kirk, on le sait, c'est un
partisan maga, on sort du devoir de
l'information et donc on biaise et donc
en fait c'est une logique commerciale,
c'est pas du tout une atteinte à la
liberté d'expression. Moi je suis pour
une liberté d'expression mais je suis
aussi pour une responsabilité des propos
que je tiens. Toi tu me donnes un micro
si je merde c'est moi qui va avoir en
répondre devant la justice.
Nous aussi avec toi.
D'accord. Mais de fait là en
l'occurrence la décision elle venait
donc des des chaînes qui sont affiliées
à la maison mer qui ont dit en fait là
votre humoriste il a déconné. Rappelons
aussi que c'est un prétexte. Le late
night show c'est terminé. Ça fait 40 ans
que ça dure. C'est donc ce type de
format d'émission qui coûte des
centaines de millions de dollars et qui
sont déficitaires. C'est c'est plus du
tout au bout du jour. Aujourd'hui, c
format, c'est des formats longs, c'est
des formats viru courts, c'est du Twitch
et que sais-je, c'est plus du tout ce
côté qui qui ils ont vieilli avec leurs
audiences et leur audience est partie.
Et donc désormais ce Jimmy Kemel, bon
voilà, on va pas pleurer sur son sœur,
il est revenu 15 jours après, il fait
des cérémonies et tout ça. Et il y a pas
il y a pas eu de personne de
l'opposition ou des de la presse qui
croupi dans des jaôles. Contrairement à
je sais pas, on a des journalistes
français qui sont des jaôles à
l'étranger sur lesquels on fait pas
beaucoup de volontarisme mais bon sort
du sujet mais tu as pas d'exemple
concret de dire il y a cette personne
qui a été poursuivie pour telle chose
moi je te refaisais juste au préalable
que Trump a eu quatre procès dont des
choses qui étaient absolument uniques
gate.
Alors ça c'était encore en 2016 mais ça
c'était des poursuites qui ont été
absolument débunquées. C'était une
procédure en destitution et un au
préalable. Mais effectivement les
poursuites dont il a fait
un canular médiatique amplifié
médiatiquement pour euh faire à charge
et qui au final euh c'est transmis enfin
c'est c'est a été vidé tout substance
euh et il y a il y a des il y a des des
motivations politiques et euh des
camouflés de justice qui ont été
employés contre Trump durant sa campagne
pour éliminer judiciairement un
adversaire politique qui était le favori
au point même ou ça c'est un autre
registre je fais pas de lien mais au
point même où on va chercher l'éliminer
physiquement Donald Trump a fait l'objet
de deux tentatives d'assassinat donc
voilà les choses ne ne sont pas liés
mais il y a eu un contexte d'hostilité
tout à fait manifeste et caractérisé.
Bon premièrement les propos de Kimul ne
justifiait pas qu'on atteigne à sa
liberté d'expression. Ces propos
n'étaient pas en contravention avec le
premier amendement. Euh secondo, les
gens qui détiennent en fait les réseaux
de diffusion, tu sais très bien que ce
sont des proches de Trump.
Donc il a fallu faire pression sur Kimul
machin. On lui a dit gentiment bien. Il
est revenu effectivement parce que
c'était un petit peu gros. Euh
maintenant je je je peux pas te
t'entendre dire que Trump passe à
travers tous les trucs. Il a quand même
été condamné pour agression sexuelle. On
est bien d'accord.
34 chef d'accusation. C'est ça
sur Eine Carole. Il a été condamné en
fait pour agression sexuelle sur une
journaliste s'appelle Jein Carole. le
truc et voilà condamné machin enfin
voilà c'est ferme
au civil au civil à New York non je pas
relativiser je par relativ les violences
sexuelles et les sexistes sont
éminamment graves sans prendre sérieux
je pense que c'était surtout par rapport
à des diffamations et moi j'ai des
réserves.
Ah mais c'est parce qu'il a continué
derrière. C'est parce qu'il a continué à
la diffamer derrière mais il a bien été
condamné pour agression sexuelle. Ça
c'est c'est acté c'est pas contestable.
C'est un fait c'est pas négociable. Il a
été condamné ensuite encore parce qu'il
a continué à la la diffam et oui
forcément il y a une deuxième
condamnation c'est tout. C'est aussi
simple que ça.
Très bien. Mais ça ça c'est enfin on
exclut volontairement, on met sous le
tapis les autres sur enfin voilà les
autres affaires qui ont été poursuivies
de manière politique. Il y a des
procureurs généraux de Manhattan là
Alvin Brag qui a fait campagne on élit
les procureurs. Il a fait campagne sur
une plateforme de dire je ferai tomber
Donald Trump. Donc bon, c'est ça un des
défauts à travers où c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut souhaiter. Est-ce qu'il y a
une élection des juges en France ou
ailleurs ? Mais en tout cas là c'était
manifeste et c'était c'était c'était
caractérisé. Mais voilà sur le fait de
dire aujourd'hui il y a une persécution
politique qui est faite, je pense que
nul n'est au-dessus de la loi et que
s'il y a des faits qui sont attestés,
ils doivent être poursuivis. On l'a bien
vu vis-à-vis de Donald Trump, ancien
président, ils ont quand même brus brisé
un un plafond de verre là-dessus et donc
qui à mon avis crée un grave précédent.
Mais aujourd'hui, il y a pas
d'instrumentalisation de la justice. Euh
et si si c'était le cas, elle devrait
être contestée ou tu devrais avoir des
exemples à me citer.
Alors non, mais ce qui va se passer de
toute façon, c'est très simple. Tu sais
très bien que euh l'échéance ça va être
les midterms, que Trump est super mal
barré qui risque un impeachment
et une condamnation parce qu'il y en a
déjà eu deux des impeachment qui ont pas
abouti. Donc est-ce que c'est un outil
politique ? Il y aura peut-être le
remove derrière, on en sait rien pour
l'instant. C'est grave en fait d'av tu
as envie d'avoir J vent qu'il soit à la
Maison Blanche. Alors ça
du tout t'inquiète c'est c'est super
grave en fait ce qu'il a fait. Il y a
une opération de dissimulation il y a
une plainte d'une gamine qui a été
instruite de 13 ans pour des actes
sexuels qui sont mais horribles,
complètement horribles. Ces documents
ont disparu. Tu sais très bien comme moi
que dans le transparency Act'était tous
les documents qu'il fallait publier.
Justifier chaque caviard d'age. Il y a
ni l'un ni l'autre qui a été fait. Moi
je remarque quein il est allé en prison
sous Donald Trump que c'est Donald Trump
qui a fait les révélations des mo que le
seul truc qui a bougé en fait c'est
Guillen Maxwell qui est passé une prison
de haute sécurité un truc club med où
elle a le droit à un animal de compagnie
quoi. Et juste après la visite de
l'avocat personnel de Donald Trump et ça
ça me dérange,
tu vois, elle a eu toutes les occasions
pour pas faire un focus sur Ain ça nous
intéresse pas.
Si ça nous intéresse,
non c'est un sujet, c'est un nom sujet
parce que tu en as pas parlé pendant 10
ans là d'un coup tu utilises ça. Nicolas
Nicolas, tu sais très bien.
Les gars, vous êtes dans la cuisine là
ou quoi ?
Non mais d'accord. Et juste pour
terminer là-dessus, c'est qu'évidemment
euh il y a il y a ce sujet qui désordre
si
j'ai envie de terminer là-dessus. Toi
aussi tu vas te détendre.
continue.
Non mais sur la question Epstein, il y a
il y a ces ces réseaux qui doivent être
instruits. Il y a euh elle a eu toutes
les occasions du monde de s'exprimer et
de voir sa peine atténuer. Désormais,
elle cherche à faire des chantages pour
obtenir une grâce présentielle. Euh moi,
j'espère à ce que cette personne-là euh
avec toute sa cruauté et son côté
malifique euh croupisse jusqu'à la fin
de ses jours en prison et ça me va très
bien comme ça.
Écoute, elle a eu un upgrade de prison à
la place quoi.
Moi je je fais pas là encore une fois le
damage contrôle vous savez là du
ministère de la justice pas ni le
ministère de la justice il a raison. OK.
Revenons à la censure. Euh si ça
commence à vriller sévère, qu'est-ce que
vous faites Nicolas ?
Mais moi je suis là. Moi je suis là pour
défendre la liberté publique. Barre. OK.
Non mais moi j'ai j'ai pas vocation à
fuir à déserter le navire. Je suis là.
Moi je suis mobilisé. J'étais là la le
lendemain de la perquisition de X où
j'ai estimé qu'il y avait une
mobilisation et une motivation
politique. J'organisais une
manifestation en mon te le reprocher ça.
Non.
Oui fa on me reproche plein de trucs
hein. Après voilà moi je je prends je
prends tout mais ça j'ai encore le droit
d'avoir une de de déclarer une
manifestation et d'organiser une
manifestation dans l'espace public.
C'était sur mes fonds propres. C'était
pour moi
combien ça t'a coûté ?
Bon ça coûte entre 5 et 10000 € de d'arm
mobilisé. Il y avait des prestataires de
sécurité de la communication du temps de
la ressource et tout ça. Donc c'est
été remboursé par X.
Bah je suis en lien avec Laurent Boaneek
juste par loyauté pour leur faire part
de ce que j'ai initié. Eux ils sont sur
un autre canal. Vous avez quand même
proposé du blé
du tout du tout.
Tu proposé de mettre du blé dans ton
sing.
Moi je leurais proposé ma production
intellectuelle. J'avais produit une note
sur le DSA et comment on peut
rééquilibrer l'enjeu. C'est pas de faire
les affaires publes.
Non ils m'ont pas payé. juste dit moi
j'alimente un réseau et je fournis de la
documentation si on peut ils ont
d'ailleurs elle a démissionné d'ailleurs
très opportunément Claire Dilly elle a
celle qui d'ailleurs témoignait auprès
de la Commission européenne alors
attention le freedom of speech la
liberté d'expression c'est pas le
freedom of rich ce n'est pas la liberté
d'amplification déjà moi j'avais
j'entendais ça j'avais la la gorge qui
se nouait un peu. Donc Claire Dilet
celle qui était responsable des affaires
publiques au niveau européen. Il s'avère
qu'elle démissionne concomutamment
opportunément 2 jours avant la
perquisition chez Mosque. Je veux pas
faire un réser du calendrier. Je dis
juste qu'il y a un poste potentiellement
qui est vacant et que moi ces questions
de liberté publique, liberté
d'expression et de menaces que peuvent
peser un système de censure
institutionnel, c'est les choses qui
mobilisent et qui peuvent mobiliser
d'autres qui ont refait les frais d'une
censéure d'état.
Et c'est pas la dame qui a été
auditionnée aussi
? Si, c'est précisément elle qui disait
"Freedom of reach is not the same as
freedom of speech". C'estàd on peut
exprimer tout ce qu'on veut mais vous
soyez pas surpris si au final on a
désamplifié votre contenu.
Mais ce que le dit aussi au passage pour
être franc.
Off.
Bah oui, parce que je te disais tout à
l'heure, on n'est pas tous égau devant
la liberté d'expression et je trouve ça
bien joli d'aller faire des
manifestations avec Philippo et qu'on
sort pour la liberté d'expression quand
on voit ce qu'ils en font. Mais bon,
mais c'est c'est le principe, je dire.
Ben oui, c'est le principe. C'est mais
le truc c'est que tu peux pas
revendiquer une liberté d'expression
sans avoir un débat sur un truc qui est
un référentiel commun, c'est de dire la
vérité. Tu vois, par exemple, des faits,
des trucs sur lesquels on peut
interagir. Euh quand tu commences à
discuter de bleu et que l'autre il te
dit rouge, ben enfin voilà, c'est tout
de suite que ça va pas ça va pas bien se
passer. Rouge, ça fait quelle couleur ?
Je
je sais même pas. Ça doit faire un
violet, un truc comme ça.
Et ça c'est le ministère de la vérité
qui a décidé ou pas ?
Mais non, c'est pas un problème de
ministère de la vérité. La vérité, si tu
veux, c'est un truc qui est euh qui est
euh qui est abstrait. Aujourd'hui, on se
retrouve avec un truc au milieu qui est
un petit peu comme les tu sais les
prêtres à l'époque. Tu as tuas tu as tu
as tu as l'information, tu as Elon Musk
et tu à nous.
Et c'est qui le prêtre ?
Le problème c'est l'algorithme en fait
que tu le prêtre en fait c'est celui qui
va te donner la parole divine. La parole
divine aujourd'hui c'est pas musque en
fait, c'est l'algorithme derrière. Moi
quand j'entends le monsieur de YouTube
qui se fait en même temps auditionner
que madame Twitter là h
et madame X euh et qui dit bon euh bon
il y a certains contenus, ils sont Legos
mais on n pas envie de les trop les voir
sur notre plateforme donc on les
débooste.
Mais évidemment enfin c'est il y a deux
trucs. Tu as un le modèle économique et
de la flip de se faire taper dessus par
bah par l'Union européenne par la
France. Monsieur Facebook, il disait
"Bon, alors les politiques, va falloir
vous mettre d'accord. Vous trouvez le
même numéro pour nous appeler parce
qu'on commence à en avoir marre d'avoir
des requêtes de ministres."
Oui, mais c'est évidemment
problématique. Je te dis là-dessus, on
est tout à fait d'accord avec Nicolas.
Il y a on est en train de monter une
usine à gaz qui ne fonctionne pas de
toute façon et euh on va se retrouver de
toute façon de bloquer un moment ou un
autre et on va être obligé peut-être pas
forcément de faire marche arrière mais
de poser sur la table de de rencontrer
ces gens-là et de leur dire bon écoutez
les histoires de Shadow Ban machin, il
faut il faut notifier les gens ou alors
au mieux on les arrête carrément et on
se dit ben voilà la limite c'est la
violence l'appel à la appel au meurtre
ce genre de truc et vous laissez les
idées s'exprimer et là oui évidemment on
va peut-être éviter quelque chose de
beaucoup plus grave.
On arrive à la fin de notre
Je pense pas qu'on y arrivera en fait.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview
parce que il y a Nicolas qui a envie de
d'arriver à la fin de l'interview.
Nicolas, je voudrais trois livres.
Alors trois livres, moi je suis un pont
transatlantique donc je vais vous donner
des référenses du nouveau monde et de
l'ancien monde.
Surtout toi qui tu dis de faire pipi.
Donc vas-y.
Des civilisation Pierre Alexandre
Beauard, un canadien qui a comment les
sociétés choisissent de leur extinction.
un Israélien qui est au ramani qui parle
des vertus du nationalisme et un
américain qui vit en Hongrie qui est
Rodreyer résister au mensonges qui pour
moi sont des des enfin qui peuvent tout
à fait nourrir un peu votre audience et
comprendre un petit peu l'enjeu des des
mécanismes à l'œuvre.
Et ton bouquin c'est quoi ?
Et évidemment mais je pensais que ça
serait tout qui en fera la promotion
c'est vers un trump français pour
l'interrogation. Non par contre je
voudrais faire un truc euh donne ton
bouquin à touff page combien ? 169
Je voudrais que tu me lises euh euh 4
livres.
Oh non, je vais laisser Nicolas à le
faire. C'est son œuvre.
Non non non non, je te demande,
j'ai l'impression de faire la promotion
du du trompis.
Ouais là là, je parlais la force de
pénétration d'un élément culturel et
voilà.
Ah non, faut que je retrouve le truc.
C'était là, il y en a qui mo Ah voilà,
c'est ça. Dans cette perspective, liste
l'amogo gauchochisme apparaît moins
comme une alliance naturelle que comme
un calcul électoral à court terme. Bon,
c'est
voilà, je fais plaisir là-dessus, mais
je parle du fait que Ayan Akam est jugé
ayant plus de valeur culturelle parce
qu'elle fait plus de likes sur YouTube
qu'une tragédie de racine somme toutes.
Voilà, c'est après effectivement, il y a
la phrase qui est un peu à l'emporte qui
est un peu facile.
Blue,
je voudrais que tu me donnes trois
livres.
Je vais t'en donner deux mais je vais
t'en donner un qui est compliqué à lire.
C'est celui de Bruno Lemè,
non ?
Le traité théologico politique donc ben
de Spinoza qui est qui est foutrement
actuel sur la sur la liberté
d'expression
et un autre qui a rien à voir mais qui
est aussi très actuel et pour cause il
est vachement plus récent, c'est
Cyberpunk d'Amala.
J'en ai pas de troisième là. Un conseil
pour les jeunes générations. Touf
participer au débat politique tout de
suite on en a besoin.
Nico, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Et ben, on a parlé de figure du prêtre.
Moi, je vais faire référence à Jean-Paul
II qui nous disait "N'ayez pas peur face
aux pressions, face à la censure, face
aux menaces, intimidations. Ayez le
courage et impliquez-vous également. Je
rejoins touff là-dessus sur ceengagement
au profit de la politique au sens noble
du terme avec un grand paix et au bien
commun.
Messieurs, merci. Merci.
[musique]